kamala harris has compared today january
6th or i should say the anniversary of
the capital riots to pearl harbor and
september 11th and
siraj where you at you know if we if we
ever needed the list we need it now well
actually no she wasn't on her phone when
she posted it she was actually speaking
on tv but the tweets went out from all
the news organizations of her saying it
and if anybody deserves to not be
speaking publicly for a little while it
would it would be her after that
statement you need only look at the
pictures of pearl harbor 911
and january 6 to know that they've
they've lost the plot they've absolutely
lost it but i tell you
you know
i don't know if they actually believe
their own you know their own bs if
they're if they're ingesting their own
refuse
but
i do think at least some of them many of
them that at least the people on the
ground the grassroots of the democrat
voter base they really believe this
stuff many of them are just tribalist
and they're angry and they want to hate
but a lot of people genuinely believe
that january 6 was as bad as 9 11. the
funny thing
though is that uh trump's approval
versus biden's approval right now if
there was an election held today trump
would win which means more americans
probably don't believe that narrative or
if the narrative
is believed they prefer insurrection in
a military coup over joe biden so how
about we just settle for yeah no no one
believes it i mean some people do but
most people don't and you're full of it
this is where we're headed politico is
actually published an article saying we
are in a new civil war oh you got me to
say it everybody take a drink tim poole
said civil war here we go but when
mainstream publications have gone from
are we in it to we are in it we should
start asking what that means what that
means for us what it means for you and
is there a way to bring everybody
together i don't know i really don't
we've uh we've got to talk about
australia they've in the northern
territories if you're unvac you can't
leave your home unless you're getting
food or or medical treatment or
providing medical treatment so it means
you can't leave your home for work
anymore it's getting more and more
severe and they have detained the number
one tennis player over highly dubious
reasons saying that his medical
exemption they're rejecting it after
letting him come then now he's in a
refugee detention center
this looks like a power flex so we'll
get into all that stuff joining us today
brandon tatum how's it going man what's
up what's up what's up how you doing
pretty good you want to introduce
yourself for those who don't know you oh
yeah brandon tatum former police officer
um i have a youtube channel called the
officer tatum uh 1.7 million subscribers
on a youtube channel bigger than us
y'all y'all more powerful than me i'm
trying to get on your level man but so i
go around the country i speak um i do
motivational speaking i do political
commentary uh so i do a lot of stuff
like that right now man thanks for
coming this will be a blessing
my pleasure before we begin i definitely
want to shout out habibi shiraj he's
been working extremely hard today it's
like his super bowl so his twitter
account is absolutely on fire today and
uh also a couple days ago on this show i
had this idea about an alien psyop
saying that in 2024 i'm gonna vote for
uh bebop uh biborp what is it beep board
b yes so the b
2024 election shirt is coming in and it
has just come in and it also has the
tagline saying bring on the next alien
psyop already and if you want to support
bbarp in 2024 you can by going to the
best political shirts dot com
and uh supporting future candidates i
love how it actually says beat boar
on your shirt and you forgot the name of
the alien you made up it happens
sometimes you know you're in this
creative flow we have no scripts here so
um yeah people 2024 that's who i'm
voting for thanks for having me this
should be a great conversation you need
like an alex jones reference because you
know he went on his show and he was
screaming that an alien intelligence has
taken over and is controlling all of
this
an ai system probably which he was
referring to which we also talked about
which which could he could not be wrong
here that's also another issue which is
worth considering centralization that
ian gets into a lot too especially when
it comes to quantum physics and energy
and entities go on and take it for sure
there's a there's a concerted effort to
put people's
collective mind state on a blockchain
and create like a mega mind that's going
to be
i think tracked is the idea but maybe we
could build one that's untracked and use
that as like the good guys tech hey i
did a little bit of research
2400 people died at pearl harbor when
the japanese empire bombed it
almost 3 000 people died on 9 11 when
the three buildings came down
and how many people died on a year ago
on january 6th well we got well yes but
i think a couple of them were one was
like someone fell so one person had a
heart attack how many bombs were dropped
a year ago
and one trump supporter was killed by a
police officer so someone made a meme
where it was like you know wikipedia
they'll do a war and it'll say like
outcome like factions casualties and
they made one for january 6 where it was
like unarmed trump supporters with flags
casualties one trump side like there was
no one no one lost their lives they
should do like a baz battles where they
do those animated battle scenes of it
where they shows like the people coming
up and the flanking and all that they
solve
that's good uh we'll need you to bring
up those numbers again when we get into
it so we also got lydia hanging out i'm
here in the corner pushing buttons as i
do i'm delighted to be back love having
brandon on it could be a great
conversation before we get started
everybody head over to timcast.com
become a member and help support our
work as a member you are funding our
team of journalists we have i think we
might have around 10. i'm not entirely
sure but we do have i think 32 employees
now we're doing a ton of stuff we're
expanding we're producing you know
cultural shows mystery investigative
shows and we are hiring more and more
journalists we actually have field
reporters on the ground covering
protests and as a member you get access
to the exclusive tim cast irl members
only podcast which go up monday through
thursday at 11 pm last night we had
marjorie taylor green
and that was i got to be honest it was
so much better than the youtube show
so much better and we decided we asked
them and i think it'll happen to do an
extended podcast exclusive off youtube
uncensored bigger conversation because
it was great and uh you know youtube
kind of sucks for the for the insane
rules they have and if we want to have
those real conversations we got to
figure out other means of distribution
so that's what we're doing you can check
that out teamcast.com don't forget to
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
let's talk about what's going on today
we have this story from timcast.com
kamala harris compares january 6 capital
riot to september 11th and pearl harbor
quote
certain dates echo throughout history
hera said including dates that instantly
remind all who have lived them
uh where they were and what they were
doing when our democracy came under
assault dates that occupy not only a
place in our calendar but a place in our
collective memory december 7th 1941
september 11 2001 and january 6 2021
wow she is the dumbest person on planet
earth this is what happened when you
sleep your way to the top and you don't
have merit behind your name or you don't
have a legitimate reputation there's
nobody on planet earth with any sense
that would compare january 6 to pearl
harbor or 9 11 i mean because you know
we're in a generation that we lived
through 9 11 and and it was
mortifying man people were getting
killed jumping out of buildings it was
literally an attack on our building
seven then just fell down yeah was it
what was it like 10 hours later right it
was it was let me let me just tell you
um but it did i'm not saying anything
about why it didn't i'm just saying
911 was so crazy i thought about this
when she said this i was like i'm
sitting there i know everyone's laughing
everyone's mocking her saying it was a
stupid thing to say and then actually
just was thinking back to like what
happened on 911 and i'm like four planes
are hijacked one of them crashes in the
field let's roll
you know they slam into these buildings
there's shrapnel and debris flying
everywhere the buildings collapse the
pentagon gets hit
peop first responders rush in there and
firefighters are dying they the epa was
right said the air was safe yep they
said it was safe to breathe go back to
work there's no problems down here now
people have what are they what do they
call it they call it 911 lung or
something like that well they have a uh
mesothelioma they have there's a bunch
of asbestos there's a word there's a
word they they associate with the people
who are down there doing the rescue
missions had for decades lung problems
from the air
and then i was there dude i was there in
the early days when when they didn't
have the guidelines everyone could walk
in there and breathe it but not only did
these buildings then collapse but 9 11
was so bad
that i think it was around what 10 hours
later another building world trade
center 7 just falls straight down that's
how crazy three buildings fell that day
and kamalaris is like they broke windows
and and and waved america and those and
those three buildings all had insurance
policies on them by larry silverstein
but that's another subject i i blame i
blame mayor willie brown for all of this
yes uh for a number of reasons but also
he's connected to 911 which i wanted to
quickly talk about since he was also
officially warned he had a flight on 911
but he said someone gave him a warning
and he cancelled his flight on the
morning i'm not allowed to say that so
yep so but mayor willie brown look that
up the mayor of san francisco um i think
it was a san francisco chronicle that
reported on this but he had a flight on
that day didn't take it and he's also
the one that helped kamala harris get
her
politics from the san francisco gate
look at this in
willie brown got low-key early warning
about air travels from september 12th
2001. this is newsguard certified
exactly look at this sf i don't make up
facts tim i got i got i got my sources i
got my documents i got my i got all my
papers and my notes right here brandon i
don't play around a couple weeks ago
luke is doing one of his signature rants
and he mentions bill gates with his
birth control microchips and then i'm
just like luke luke no no stop stop and
looks like it's real look i google it
right here and bill gates funded birth
control microchips it's a real thing
it's the new alex jones right here i
don't know about that there's a lot of
stuff i have to stop myself from saying
right all right well hold on hold on uh
i want to bring this up sfgate
has got a 100 out of 100 on newsguard
and they reported september 12th isn't
one willie brown got a low-key early
warning about air travel quote it was
not an abnormal call i'm always
concerned if my flight is going to be on
time and they always alert me when i
ought to be careful exactly where the
call came from is a bit of a mystery the
mayor would say only that it came from
my security people at the airport it's
interesting i wonder uh telling them not
to fly on 911. that's a big deal right
there
that's the person also connected to
kamala harris but i i've heard recently
that kamala harris and mayor willie
brown are not on on talking uh
what's the phrase here they're not on
speaking terms uh but but obviously
kamala harris has risen to power and
she's using it to spread fear and to
divide and conquer this nation in so
many disingenuous ways it's absolutely
horrifying to see this kind of
comparison made to some of the most
tragic life lost that happened
domestically in the united states it's
it's disgusting i want to do the
opposite of um what you know the
democrat establishment and the media do
and actually lydia messaged me saying
freedom day yes and i was like it's a
good idea so here's what i tweeted never
forget january 6 also known as freedom
day will forever be the day we remember
the 100-day siege on the u.s from the
white house to federal courthouses to
small-town america dozens lost their
lives to the democrat-supported carnage
this was the george floyd riots
the white house was besieged they set a
guard building on fire they set the
church on fire it was one of the most
intense assaults on the white house
we've seen since 1812.
yossi gestetner with that tweet he says
way worse than what happened on january
6th
we had small town america ransacked
buildings smashed up
we need to talk about that yeah we need
we need to talk about they they they
were not only in dc over the summer they
were all over the country
so
one of one of the issues i have with the
culture war is that the right component
whatever you want to call it
just follows the lead in the news cycle
of the new york times and cnn quick side
note here uh today is also the national
bean day according to google but also
kamala harris when those larger protests
were going on she was bailing people out
that were committing crimes against
innocent civilians there was dozens of
people that were killed during these
riots and we can't talk about it sorry
i'm talking too much no i i agree with
you a thousand percent this is this is
out of control that we are in this
position in our country where we just
completely avoid the fact that people
were burning down buildings and killing
people and terrorizing
it is the it is this the definition of
domestic terrorism is what blm
people that represent blm or claim to
represent blm were doing
throughout the entire summer
over nothing
at least at least i can say people that
may have an argument on january 6 they
have a certain argument that they have
about the election they thought that
they were going to stop a faulty
election for going through that's not
i'm not saying i take their position
necessarily but that's what they were
attempting to do
blm
a black man gets shot justifiably by
police
briana taylor was never she wasn't
sleeping to bed they completely create
these entire lives and burn down
communities hundreds of hundreds of
thousands millions of dollars worth of
damage people were dying getting hurt i
think it was only 2 billion yeah around
the country yeah it could probably
easily been over 2 billion and none of
these things get replaced people can't i
mean the livelihood has not come back
these people some people have been
killed their lives are not going to be
replaced and people are arguing about
individuals who went into the capitol
building some of them were let in some
of them were taking selfies i just saw a
video that was posted i think i shared
on one of my social media platforms of
the guy that had the horns or whatever
he's going there it's like three dudes
in there the police is asking hey is
everybody okay they're just chilling you
know you talk about pearl harbor you
must be smoking crack to think that that
is comparable what a what a what a
disrespect to the men and women who
served this country the men and women
who were fighting on september 11th that
they have had residual effects that have
happened people have died skin blown off
i mean the images that we saw people
jumping out of buildings and hitting the
ground from 100 stories high and you're
talking about the capitol building that
didn't last long enough that they
finished the vote the same day yeah it
took like three hours for this whole
thing to go through and then they were
fixing the whole thing they went through
and they got done with the election and
they finalized it and everything and i
was posting those images from kamala
harris supporting the
minneapolis freedom fund talking about
how they set free this guy who had
committed egregious acts against a child
and all these sources that gone through
and fact checked it and they couldn't
even say it was false they're like well
this needs context you know well this
isn't the full story but yeah no her
freedom fund said a bunch of people a
bunch of criminals free like child
predators free huh like one guy
apparently was like reportedly a child
predator yeah that's what i'm saying
that guy yeah but republican republicans
are so weak though
yep ted cruz is a weenie
all these people are so old
soft man i mean how can you go home and
kiss your wife and act like you're the
man of the house right you're such a
weenie yeah he may have he may as well
ever
have resigned when he said that was a
terrorist attack yeah i mean what was he
who's he's going to win he's an
establishment brown-noser and he always
was an establishment brown-noser from
the very beginning and he's trying to
placate the middle allegedly this is the
kind of the i you know we actually
talked to someone who was around his
circles uh recently and and when he was
responding to this he's trying to show
the republicans that he's going to be
the opposite of trump he's going to be
the moderate uh considerable considerate
republican uh but it's absolutely
ridiculous because of just how brown and
gooey and nasty his nose is with all the
butt kissing he's doing to the
establishment it's it's what we're doing
what world is he living in i don't know
people love trump i mean i was just last
night there was this rapper named kevin
gates he's a gangster rapper well-known
dude in the rap industry
i just so happen cause i follow him i
just so happen to see him on live and
he's talking about trump and saying oh
trump was cold i mean we need trump back
in office i mean and there was a bunch
of other dudes on there from the hood
from the community with mad respect
and they all agreed that trump was the
one of the best things that ever
happened to our country at least during
their lifetime you got to be crazy to
think that somehow they're going to
leave donald trump who was the answer to
the prayers of many people of having a
person in office that's not a a
politician somebody who's an outsider
somebody's going to stand up for for
america you think you're going to you're
going to somehow swindle your way into
that i got it he's he's trying to get
that job on the view yeah
check it out he'd be great for it the
view can't find a female conservative
because they've stated they want someone
who's popular among the right
but who doesn't believe trump won the
election
and you you basically can't get it i
think it's 71 percent in the latest poll
of republicans believe trump won and so
they want someone so why would so so ted
cruz comes out and he calls it a terror
attack it's not it's not even
necessarily about trump
if you're someone who pays attention to
the news like you actually read and
investigate you know it wasn't a terror
attack it was in one area the tunnel a
riot and on the sides people walked in
confused
the magamima as they call them just
bumbling around that nor macdonald tweet
the violent you know insurrectionists
respected the the velvet ropes
just walking in like idiots like no idea
was going on so when you see that you're
like yeah that was not terror and you
see on reddit they have that photo of
that officer the capital officer who
like baited them and led them away and
i'm like these guys were those guys like
it wasn't one group of people who plan
to do anything and the fbi has even said
that so to come out and for ted cruz to
say terrorist attack he's trying to
convince
democrats yeah who hate him to vote for
him
that's the crazy thing that's what
that's what i'm wondering like what is
his angle what who is telling him to do
this it's the dumbest thing in the world
democrats hate you you're racist uh
sexist homophobic whatever they can name
you that's what you are to democrats and
people on the left and then everybody
else well i say everybody else there's a
there's a small group of people in the
middle but the people in the middle
aren't stupid enough to watch you go out
and project theater
as a politician and think that you're
genuine well people can see through ted
cruz i don't think there's a center
anymore i mean it technically is i think
this show is fairly moderate some people
have described it as like centrists
right leaning a little bit and maybe
it's because of the other influences of
people on the show
but we're not the you know hardcore maga
maga hat wherein we're not you know
conservative ink suit wearing like tp
usa or anything like that we're uh
an eclectic bunch i don't even know what
ian is it's in motion you know it's not
static uh whether it's on the right on
the left we're constantly swirling
around the center and getting a little
bit from both sides wait wait maybe
that's you and your consciousness i
don't like any of these politicians i
think they're all sellouts i think
they're all working for the special
interest and i think they'll take any
opportunity that they can to skin you
alive in the journal
do you think trump is a part of that
absolutely 100
especially with his endorsement of big
pharma especially with him sitting down
with henry kissinger during the start of
his presidency as soon as i seen that i
said okay that's game over as soon as
he's congratulating and saying how great
he is that's that that had everyone's
eyebrows out when he was talking about
auditing the federal reserve
investigating 911 releasing the jfk cia
files he did none of that i agree trump
i i think this is more trump got into
the office and they pulled him they
pulled him away trump is undoubtedly an
outsider and so there were things i
think he was trying to get done i do not
believe he's part of the swamp i think
he's his own kind of different swap
monster
maybe that's how i see it myself he got
in like i've been watching um oliver
stone just released a kennedy
documentary about the assassination i
was just watching another one last week
like i think he got in and realized that
okay there's really a moving organism
here that if i disrupt too much it will
reject me as part of the system like if
you put a little uh
i wonder man i don't think he's a part
of some cabal or something's crazy like
that i really do think that
he did the best he could with what he
had but i do think he's he's in a
position where you know people expect
him to be perfect and he's not perfect
you know and this
i'ma call him out when it's time to call
him out but i do think because of his
history and what he's lived through even
a generational gap between us and him is
that some of these things he actually
believe are true and necessary like when
he came out on canon's own show and he
said all the the dumbest thing i've ever
heard in my life
i think he actually mean that the guys
that i smoke with in the cigar lounge
that are his age are around his age they
all see the world the same way that he
does i
i think trump was an avatar of the anger
of you know the american working class
populists who are sick of the system and
and as michael moore put it trump was
that human molotov cocktail but
trump was uh
imperfect he's the imperfect avatar he
he wasn't he was just that that
embodiment of anger for a lot of people
he did things they liked
you're never gonna get someone perfect i
guess he over promised and he
compromised a lot but he did try to at
least enter some kind of conversations
into the dialogue that did make him look
like a bull in a china shop and he did
have the corporate media scared he did
have the establishment scared somewhat
but i think he also was trying to be
liked by them at the same time and his
ego got in the way and from my
perspective there was a lot of
possibilities there and i think he he he
failed on a lot of those possibilities
but again i don't want to be one of
those crazy leftist lunatics that has
trump derangement syndromes when he did
something good i i always complimented
him and gave him respect and props for
standing up for certain issues and and
making the debates and and arguments
that everyone was afraid to make so so
you know let's be honest anyone who's in
power deserves to be criticized no
matter what and we shouldn't always
worship celebrities because when you
when we do bad things happen well i i
agree and the reason i brought up like
the kind of the whatever space this show
occupies is that
if if we are you know if luke is on this
show and looks like we got to criticize
all of these people we're certainly not
the ardent trump can do no wrong crowd
and if we look at what ted cruz said
like he's a lunatic then i don't know
who he's going after because you know
i've seen these tweets where they're
like where's the middle ground between
the the january 6 was an insurrection
and january 6 was no big deal and it's
like we talk about it all the time and
so do most of our guests like the riot
was bad uh these people who were
engaging in violence should be
prosecuted and you know we don't want
something like that to happen but it
certainly was an insurrection of course
there's middle ground
ted cruz is not occupying that so
pandering to democrats who hate you and
souring yourself on even moderates who
think it's a stupid thing to say i think
he's basically just
he may as well have just resigned and
said i'm done i'm not going to run again
maybe that's the plan to flip texas
democrat in the senate or something i
have no idea yeah i don't know i mean
maybe it's arrogance maybe he's just out
of touch these people are corny
individuals like when you meet them in
person you're like dude you still got a
politician hat on dude we just sitting
here talking why are you you know using
certain words and acting like you're in
in campaign mode some of these people
are not real individuals i don't even
know if they they if they go home are
they still wearing a suit and trying to
uh campaign to their wife or something
or whatever to their kids i don't know
if they're real people campaigning to
get laid to their right right i'm gonna
tell you why tonight is gonna be the
best five minutes of your life
five minutes that's right i won't over
promote over promise
yeah no they are man and and i tell you
we've we've reached out to a lot of
politicians and we've been reached out
to by a lot like a lot of politicians
have reached out and it you i feel like
even the people watch you can tell
you can tell when there's a brandon
tatum sitting down having a real
conversation and when there's a
politician getting ready for something
yeah well i i think politicians and
people always say you should be a
politician i don't i don't like it man
it's too grimy too dirty and i'm too
real um maybe one day i may have to but
i will never be a guy that's gonna sit
up here and read talking points and this
is what i should say because the people
think i'm just me if you don't want to
vote for me don't vote for me i don't
know why people feel like they got to
put on a character it's like it's like
online dating right
people put a facade out there and they
want to present themselves as being a
certain way and then you meet them in
person you're like oh you're not really
who you said you was you built the
facade you only put out the things that
are positive about you
people should just be real
there should be a rating score on online
dating apps when people give you reviews
of five stars yeah that's necessary
absolutely sorry go ahead and i guess
you get into a long-term dang situation
it's just would be irrelevant i guess
like i found the one it's over and you
close the account but no one does they
keep their accounts open yeah so i want
to talk about this next segment but i do
uh want to i want to give you guys an
update so last night we had marjorie
taylor green on the show she was
absolutely fantastic and one of the
things that came up was dan crenshaw
being listed by the world economic
forum's young uh was it young global
leaders thing yeah but pete buddha judge
and tulsi gabbard buddha jesus was a
different year so i actually uh reached
out to dan crenshaw and he i'll give you
the gist of of his statement paraphrase
basically
his understanding or i should say my my
takeaway from what he said is that this
is an editorial list here that they have
nothing to do with it's like uh so i
asked him is this like forbes 30 under
30 like the world economic forum just
decides these are people we think you
should watch and he was like yes there
was no communication involved they just
put me on some list
and now he's like people see that and
they think i'm associated in some way i
i think it's important that you know
people hear his response because we did
pull that up and i even said i don't
know what this young global leaders
thing is
and if it turns out that the davos group
just like makes a list of people they're
interested in whether you realize it or
not i don't want to smear the guy over
something someone else does and i agree
with you but why would they pick him
right yeah i mean
there's god they're not gonna
they're not going to pick marjory green
they're not going to pick certain people
so why don't they pick you and i'm
telling what man my wife cannot stand
him you know and she just think that he
is a part of the establishment i
remember and i and i can't verify that
unequivocally i remember when he first
came out and i said yeah i like this
dude military guy he's bad to the bone
missing the eye this is the dude and
then he started it's like they get in
office and they start getting softer and
softer and softer and before you know it
they're acquiescing in this way they're
they're trying to be cool with these
people and they're in the middle they're
not like marjorie green like i'm not
expecting anybody to be radical but i'm
expecting you to go in there and tear
stuff up i'm expecting you to go in
there and stand your ground and stand on
the principles that people are asking
you to stand on you got elected because
you had these campaign videos of you
being outside of coming in and serving
your community and because you were you
were in you know in the military but
then you get in there and you just
shrink down
and and you just like to everybody else
and and and it's easy for me to talk
because i'm not in politics but like
is that what happens to you when you get
in the podcast the ones that want
marjorie taylor green yeah she's not you
know but
amazing and i and i love her i met her
before she ever was in politics and i
remember we were at some conference and
she was like i'ma run for office and i
remember you know she was such a cool
person in the fitness and but like how
long is she going to last i'll tell you
she does shows like this for a long time
i'll tell you around i hope so i hope
she hopes the big thing for me was it's
all about the media they're they're you
know she's she said you know cookie
things on facebook back in the day she
apologized for those things i don't i
don't know if i agree with her on all of
her policy positions but when she said
she went down to congress and forced
roll call votes to make all the members
actually come down and have to vote on
these bills i was just like that
deserves a standing ovation absolutely
making these people do their jobs and i
got messages from people where they were
like as soon as i heard that i was like
i'll vote for cause like all of her
policy positions aside if she's going
there and telling all these members of
congress get down here vote and do your
jobs
i'll take it and show the constituents
what you're voting for because otherwise
that would be hidden from them so
holding them account to the point where
even republicans are mad at her and
democrats are mad at her because they
can't just pass through all these bills
really fast i think that's great i think
the the more we have
you know the stagnation in government
the better government we have that's my
own personal perspective that's how i
see it because when they're arguing and
fighting amongst each other they're not
trying to put government on someone else
and they've been put in a lot of
government on a lot of people and she's
stopping it somewhat but i think she i
think she's a great example for all
americans
that if you feel the call to serve you
don't have to be some politician you
don't have to have some legacy of
political a political background and
that's true for aoc as well i want to be
i want to do this because i feel like i
want to make a difference and if you
pursue it because i remember her saying
she was going to do it before she ever
did it and she pursued it and she won
and and i and i think you're correct
about alc even though i think she's
dumber than a bag of rocks
um well i i i
ancient rocks i'm not going to
disrespect them like that so let me not
be superfluous i think that her
arguments are poor
i think that she believes what she's
saying though and that's why she's been
so successful i i honestly believe that
afc i disagree man you don't think she i
think she's dumb enough to believe every
time they come out and they say like hey
aoc i'm criticizing you for this thing
you did she goes you just want to date
me
i think she's dumb enough to believe
that
she think people want to sleep with her
you know
um my i i don't like
you know we make fun of her for being
dom and all that stuff i'm actually not
a fan of doing that i don't like her i i
do think she is lacking in inability i
think she's a master of marketing she's
a master of media manipulation
but uh
i i you know i don't know i wanna i
wanna make sure that we when we when we
when we present criticisms it's
substantive you know what i mean and i
agree i agree
yeah sometimes we you know sometimes i
go over the top and i may say certain
words because that's how i really feel
but in actuality you have to say look at
the critique of what she's doing she
literally came on television and bashed
people for not wearing masks she bashed
them she'd been bashing desantis
and she's literally in his state
drinking and having a good time hugging
people kissing and partying that's only
what we saw on camera she was probably
living her best life but she get on tv
and she make these claims she talks
about climate change oh we're gonna all
die in 13 years or something it's
irreversible
but i guarantee you she got on a jet a
plane and flew to miami renting the car
probably and is driving around living
her best life these people
they're either dumb or they're evil
that's one of the two and i think it's
an evil dude it could be both and i'm
not trying to be superfluous in the in
my description of her i just really do
think that these people are
evil or they are
completely out of their mind they're
ignorant because they think climate
change is not going to be stopped
they're ignorant because it can be we
can withdraw the carbon from the
atmosphere
it's got to be evil and i'll tell you
why didn't obama buy beachfront property
yeah of course he did the banks are
giving him 24. so here's so that bill
gates
so these people that come out and claim
all this stuff climate change and
whatever
they do the opposite when i see marjory
taylor green refusing to wear a mask and
she know and she's got i think she was
saying like you know ninety thousand
five thousand fines or something accrued
from all the stupid bs she's going down
to the house nancy below she's like
everybody gotta wear mask and she's not
gonna do it that's consistent with what
she said she's doing what she says right
when aoc says texas is you know
effectively going to killing people by
ending the mass mandates and then she
chooses not to wear a mask in florida
but criticizes desantis you can see how
she really feels when no one tells her
she has to she won't so it's not about
wearing the masks it's about the
government mandating people do it yeah
so it's like well i think it's evil too
because it's like you know
the position
and the facts but you present something
different to the people because you want
to toe the line because you want to get
reelected why would you do people like
that when you don't practice what you
preach let's put it this way
no matter what no matter which direction
you go it's evil here's why
if she thinks masks
really will save lives and then you have
to have them
then she goes to part and parties
without one thinking she'll be killing
people by doing that that's kind of evil
that sounds evil yeah willfully putting
people at risk at least based on that
belief that masks are important or she's
claiming masks are important and doesn't
actually believe it and is just lying to
toe some tribal line
also evil dude
it's a career move right these people
this is what i'm learning about politics
these people want to stay in office as
long as they can because when you're in
office it's not just your little salary
you get you know 170 thousand dollars
you get in the house representatives
every two years or whatever i mean you
know you got a 1.4 million dollar budget
right so per year i think it is but you
know how many butts they kissing and how
many people they doing deals with behind
the scenes you staying there long enough
you're gonna be you're gonna be set for
the rest of your life and i often wonder
is this what they're really doing it for
is she doing this to secure the bag for
the rest of her life
pointing out lies that she know aren't
true but she have to push those to get
reelected because she really don't care
i mean she don't care about other people
she it didn't appear that she does i
don't know this crazy data like this cnn
analyst saying that masks are facial
calling them facial decorations on tv
like this is leanna wen said this two
weeks ago like so how about cnn on cnn
cnn so how confusing for someone to be
like you're supposed to wear a mask but
then the cnn guidance comes out or the
analyst and says
they're not they don't function properly
this is your issue
it's it's almost like um you know people
bring up yuri besmanov all the time just
confuse and demoralize the population
keep them in a constant state of chaos
so they can't figure out what's going on
what they're supposed to do
and the politicians are also in that
state so well let's go we'll go back to
how she ended up being brought up we're
talking about you know first it was dan
crenshaw you know he's he's arguing with
marjorie taylor green
you know we we had uh we had uh mtg on
and i think the member segment we did
with her it was getting it was getting
legit and i'm like man i really want to
have like a longer form off youtube so
we can just go deep dive on a bunch of
topics because when we do the youtube
show it's very topical it's very direct
topical we mostly talked about her and
censorship and and congress and what was
going on in congress and then we started
getting to the nitty gritty of just like
the thing she's talked about in the past
how she feels how she feels about
vaccine mandates and it was raw and it
was real and then i was just like man
she was swearing and i'm like it did not
feel like the other politicians we've
had on the show who are worried about
offending one side or the other and
trying to get votes it felt like she was
just like i'm here and i'm going to tell
you what i think and i was like man
that's that's what people like about
trump yes that's what people like about
mtg you know we're so sick of the
inauthentic fake bs in politics we will
take something that seems genuine and
unfortunately for the populist left the
people they brought on they're all just
disingenuous well let's be honest aoc
talks a big game but when pelosi says
step in line she steps in line and votes
like pelosi wants her to vote but she
also mastered social media and she also
mastered the way of engaging with people
and exploiting that to its fullest
extent and there are algorithms that of
course are pushing her messaging out to
millions and millions of people
in an unrestricted way which of course
is something that the other side does
not have so when you have direct lines
through the algorithm to the youth
you're able to influence them especially
when you set up a gaming channel i mean
this person i don't think she's dumb i
think she's very smart i think she's
very very calculated it might have been
a mistake that she got caught without
you know wearing a mask in florida uh
ron desantis said that this is quote uh
a ruling class mentality and i think
that has more kind of perspective to it
but but look what she did with with
january 6th look how she involved
herself in that event she lied when she
lied about being at the capitol no no so
you know i i when this story came out
aoc claimed that she thought the writers
had made it to her her office she made
that up the timeline made no sense i saw
ben shapiro tweeting it and i tweeted
him like yo it's not it's not that she's
you know making up the fear it's that
the whole story is fabricated i couldn't
believe how many people on the right
didn't catch this
when the cop knocks on her door and aoc
is like so then i'm like i'm in i hide
in the bathroom and i'm thinking like
they found me or whatever and then i
hear where is she and it's the most
exaggerated insanity ever and then she's
thinking she was going to die or
whatever she said when i saw that story
i was like wait
you know i actually argued the
huffington post guy in through direct
messages because because i said you know
when she came out in the hallway there
were already a bunch of people there
being evacuated so where was she she
wasn't in the capital she was in her
building then people said yeah but the
capital does connect through tunnels to
that building and then i was like why
when did the rioters make it to the
tunnels they didn't did they think they
were gonna why do they think that and
then
i actually went through the timeline of
when she said it was this time it was
like one o'clock when she was getting
her food and she had a knock on the door
and i went at one o'clock not a single
rioter had even made it to the building
yet
it was it was they had just breached the
first barricade
no one knew what had happened and the
police it was that famous video where
the cops fanning people in
there it wasn't until i think an hour
later that the writers actually breached
the building do you think she's an hour
later do you think she's being honest
but had her timeline wrong no that makes
no sense how is she being honest she so
so that would mean that if she was being
honest she was in her office the cop
knocked on her door and then she had a
psychic premonition of people raiding
the capitol
they're going to raid the capital and
they might be here now right now
no one knew that was gonna happen she
lied made the whole thing up and and
i've been to the capitol building i've
been to the halls of congress it it's
difficult to figure that that building
out to go through the tunnel it's very
difficult
of course we had to get escorted and
they showed us how to get down there and
if you were down there for the first
time you don't know where it goes you
don't know where to go where door to go
out to is it's real it's a big uh
hallway in the middle where they got
trains and stuff going through there and
so it's like come on man i mean she she
is a liar it's the same thing people the
left does this well and the reason why
is age
youth
she
is in the era of social media
republicans don't have a lot of young
people involved
and therefore they are not capturing the
social media you know frenzy and they're
not getting the reach that aoc is
getting if you notice it's the older
people that don't even use facebook i
mean some of the people some of the
republicans probably don't even know how
to use social media at this point
they're not good at it that's why we are
let's say we i'm a republican that's why
we should get younger people involved
like marjorie um i think it's marjorie
margie marjorie madrid
right she's younger in the 30 40 range
she's not 60 50 60. she's healthy
i hear you're saying but it is kind of
scary that
there's she's the old that she's the
young one
right i mean how do she gonna beat you
up next time she sees it no
i'm just messing with you no we gotta we
gotta be real i guess i was like i don't
wanna call her old or anything like that
because she's only 47. but uh uh that
it's kind of crazy that
we need millennials because we don't
have term limits we need time limits
because otherwise you're going to get
these 80 year olds it's not cool though
politics are not cool you can run for
office when you're 75 for the first time
i feel like i feel like trump made it a
little more cool you know a little more
dynamic you don't have to be a
politician to be in office so but it's
not sexy to be a politician it's but
people need to make it that way and i
feel like i feel like aoc for the left
she made it cool the kennedy
assassination made it not cool for me
like i can't get in there and speak my
mind because i'm afraid that they're all
watching me and they know where i sleep
like that's i'm not comfortable with
that if a president gets in there they
really want to change the system they're
going to need to duck out of the country
for a while because the cia is not going
to like it this system is like in place
for a reason
yes it's scary i know politics can twist
it open i don't but when you're young i
mean most people that probably should be
in politics don't desire to be in
politics right and the people that do
desire beating politics are people
probably who are power hungry and
narcissistic and that's how they end up
getting in paradise and they get power
and then they love it sociopaths yeah
and so it's unfortunate but like
i don't know how to fix it but younger
people need to feel more confident that
look this is our country yeah we need to
take it
like it needs a bunch of things have to
happen at once we need young new
intelligent politicians we need new
pieces of technology and new shows that
are being developed that are like
invigorating the entire process but it
has to happen all at once it can't be
one or the other right i'm just not the
person that can get into politics
because of my mind state it's too
dangerous for me let's just uh
jump off the the metaphorical cliff with
this next article from politico they
write we are in a new civil war about
what exactly grievous conflicts have
been about big things war slavery
depression but this time we just don't
like each other spoken like a true
establishment democrat personality who
doesn't know anything about the right or
moderates or libertarians or
post-liberals this article says to me oh
they've recognized there's anger there's
a conflict but they're so ignorant to
what's been going on they think we just
don't like each other
that to me is absolutely incredible let
me just start with
barack obama killed children let's uh
national defense authorization act and
definite detention provision uh
spying nsa spying um the prosecution of
journalists and whistleblowers and then
let's move on to more more towards the
end uh hillary clinton deleting 30
thousand emails getting away with it and
the establishment lying and protecting
how about this russia gate ukraine gate
the covington kids over and over
benghazi lies benghazi afghanistan
now i can complain about the things
trump did with the commando raids in
yemen and the drone strikes upping the
drone strikes missile strikes in syria
too and i can tell you we i i think most
people in this country are pissed off at
the establishment for those reasons and
many many more but what do they say we
just don't like each other no no you
don't know this faction of the
establishment zombie npcs they don't
they just hate
they hate or they're ignorant they don't
read they don't care to learn and they
don't want to hear what you have to say
but the conflict we are seeing bubble up
from i guess the american populists be
it moderate left and right then you have
the establishment left there's real
reasons
why there's a conflict happening yeah i
think i think that that's true but the
lay man the average american they hate
each other don't even know why
people people hate their neighbors
and
i i agree with you to a certain degree
because i do think that there's reasons
why but a lot of people cannot even
articulate the reason why they don't
like trump why do you think it is where
do you think it comes from people are
dumb we've been dumbed down through
technology through the school system
people are they're such sheep and maybe
we've always been this way but this is
what i'm saying right
you ask the average trump supporter do
you watch trump speak
they'll probably say yes
and that's why they they like him how
many people have we heard they used to
be democrats and then they decided to
vote for trump after they actually
listened to the man
what the media had done the
establishment with articles like this
what are we mad about exactly
they don't tell their audience what's
really happening they show trump in the
worst possible light i saw a reddit post
and it was like one of the top posts and
it said for the life of me i don't
understand why this wasn't the end of it
and it was a picture of trump doing the
arm thing and it said trump mocks
disabled reporter they set trump up with
that and if you actually watch the video
trump supporters said trump insults
everyone in the same way saying oh jeez
oh geez it has nothing to do with the
reporter in general when you realize
that trump insults everybody that way
you're like oh he's just an [ __ ] yeah
it wasn't directed at one disabled guy
but the media lied about it yeah then
all of a sudden you're like okay i get
it he's kind of a dick but what is he
saying and then you actually listen to
what he has to say and you're like wow
the media told me he was a white
supremacist now it turns out he just
wants to bring factories back
all of a sudden people vote for him i
just kind of want to add a little bit to
your point that you were making in the
beginning i think it's fair to
acknowledge that the establishment has
been screwing over the average person
for a very long time whether it's the
wars the banker bailouts the hyper money
printing there's a lot of problems that
are artificially created for the benefit
of the ruling elite in the united states
that screws over the average american
and then they have the gall to say it's
his fault and they're doing this with
social conditioning they're doing this
with the algorithms they're doing this
with trauma-based mind control and
emotional manipulation and they're
saying all of your problems that we
caused how we we laced you we skinned
you we screwed you over your neighbor's
the problem and and some people are
actually believing it and buying that
bag of lies and and to me this is why
we're such we're so close towards this
conflict which again we should do
everything in our power to try to avoid
sorry you had something to say as well
one more point real quick sorry um i
just want to reiterate a point that we
brought up on a couple other shows
lauren beaubert
made fun of biden for saying true nana
shabbat to pressure when he when he had
that gaffe she said biden has never
fulfilled his promise of getting us true
nana shabbat of pressure or whatever and
the response from the democrat activist
base was
what is she trying to say her brain is
finally rotted oh no look how dumb she
is was she what was she trying to type
they didn't know joe biden said that
because they don't watch the news and
politico and cnn these outlets don't
inform them of what's actually going on
so they live in this bubble world echo
chamber where they hate everyone outside
of it and the people outside of it you
know acro beyond the fire have seen all
the different aspects of reality in the
nuance that's the conflict can we play
the true and honest shout out to
pressure at some point well i'll pull it
up while you you you know you hit the
nail on the head because that's how i
became republican and not why i voted
for trump is because i want to win his
rallies now first and foremost i'm
open-minded and that's what people need
to get to the point where they can say
let me open my mind up and hear both
sides of an argument before i make a
decision but i went to a rally a trump
rally and i think it was 2015 2016. and
i went in there and he was supposed to
be this racist dude throwing black
people out of his rallies for no reason
illegally all this sort of stuff i went
there to do was cool
he was saying all the things that i
believe i'm like and he and he did it
with passion he did it
authentically all of the above and then
i found out that he wasn't throwing
people out of his events illegally he
was buying or renting these spaces
as a private event and you can in a
private event you can ask people to
leave and if they refuse to leave they
can be arrested for trespassing that's
what he did he gave an announcement
before every rally that he did and all
of that blew my mind as a police officer
and i said you know what these people
are lying
and i'll say this too about the
republicans is that the republicans need
to do a good job at recruiting and
converting but they don't they
but the republicans don't do the
converting the democrats do
i didn't become a i didn't become a
republican because of republicans i
can't recruit them because these crazy
democrats all of my friends all my dad
everybody
they go so crazy these leftists they go
so wacky that it push people away and
then they end up going to the other side
would you start a new political party uh
it's too late yeah it's too late because
you know you still have people in this
country that are rational right
there's the radical and then there's the
rational people and i think a lot of
rational people still have rational
ideas within the republican party and
believe that it could actually
um be
you know rescued like if you get another
party it just you're going to split the
vote i'm going to try i want to play
this clip just real quick effective
strategy to mobilize true international
depression i'll need an effective
strategy to mobilize true international
depression
i want the cheering after that
it's the way the crowd cheers after he
says it it's like this cult of like they
don't even know what he said but they're
like yeah that's another thing i was
like when he says trinidad shabbat
pressure or whatever and batacaf care
everyone goes yeah
it's like what they're cheering just for
the fact that he made a noise it doesn't
even matter what he said they don't even
know that's usually politics
i mean the guy the guy is showing early
signs of mental deterioration i mean
it's not even a joke i mean the fact
that he's stumbling over his words he
he talks straight he don't know where
he's at half of the time this proves
that the president is not in charge this
proves that someone else is calling the
shots that's from my perspective that's
how i see it that's my opinion i know we
disagree and we can maybe we can debate
this later but evidence maybe no no no
no hold on it's a good point luke i
disagree with you i think your opinion
is valid in my opinion
i think he's sitting at the table
whacked out of his mind kamala harris
doesn't care and he's telling people we
gotta you know
he's he's in this like the situation
room you got libya
come on man and then they're like okay
and they'll look around at each other
and they're like you got it and they
walk out of the room like what do we do
like withdrawals
let's just move some ships around and
then they do
like i think
joe biden is just muttering and
sputtering and they just say when you
look at kamala harris not going to the
border
that's i don't think that's an issue of
by not running the show i think it's an
issue of them being like i don't know
man i don't care biden says she's the
borders aren't she's like i ain't doing
it what's he cause he's not he's gonna
forget so i don't care i think there's a
whole bunch of blackrock corporate
executives or dark suits sitting with
literal strings on biden and pulling him
every step of the way as he moves but
that's just my own perspective and
opinion but i also wanted to add i think
this concept of of civil unrest of a
civil war it's not a crazy one newsweek
had a very important article today and
they were talking about how civil unrest
historically is the norm after pandemics
and they talked to two political
scientists and they said between 1300
between the 1300s black death and the
1918 spanish flu there were 57 pandemics
and there was only four cases of them
that didn't result in a revolt or
large-scale protest afterwards and they
actually announced a number of times so
the cops just walked in yeah i don't
know what's going on here
uh
should we uh yeah that i
i was looking at my notes and i was like
somebody did somebody swatch you yep
somebody swatted us did they remind us
yep somebody swatted us how do you know
how do you know i have somebody texting
me
oh okay
wow so
yeah
just a police officer entered here
looked around because it looks like
someone swatted this live broadcast here
they're coming here busting man
yeah i mean
that's that's something that's extremely
dangerous extremely reckless
because you know swat incidences have
led to a lot of innocent people dying
dogs being shot people being shot people
thinking that their house is being
raided by criminals defending themselves
so
whoever did that and they're listening
like
yeah those things those things you know
and and it's a it's a healthy a healthy
penalty if you get caught swatting
that's a felony crime and you can spend
years in jail over because
the inherent risk if a police officer
you know believes that that's what it's
confirmed if the police officer believes
that there's who knows what they said
you know they could have said somebody
is screaming a kidnap someone's
kidnapped here we need to send you just
say and i heard a boom i heard a boom i
don't know if you're in that door loud
they hit so what if we were in here you
know and we saw him and we pulled the
trigger on him yeah we're in the
shootout with the police you can get
them hurt we can get hurt you know it's
crazy did that happen all right let's
let's let's let's let's uh no we never
got caught i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you
guys what just happened
uh i just walked out of the room the
cops walked in they walked around with
flashlights we've been swatted i am
extremely unhappy with this because
i can't necessarily be mad at the
officers they were very polite but i do
not like cops coming into my house when
we have mats all over the place they
come back with the warrant yeah
and
i don't know who let them in or why what
happened uh i understand they're here
because we got swatted a report was made
that two people had been shot and killed
and that the gunman was threatening to
to hurt themselves
they didn't send a swat team it was just
a couple of officers i want to drag them
or be mean to them because
they were polite
but i'm not happy with the idea that
they're walking into our studio while we
are live they're walking around
cop immediately i walked out of the room
he immediately come up and said i'm
really really sorry about this we're not
trying to you know screw with you or or
ruin what you're doing here's what
happened we got a call two people had
been shot and killed and a person was
going to be killing themselves we have
to check it out make sure everything's
okay we're going to be doing a sweep
once we figure it out and i'm just like
go back with a warrant but i have to say
this is what i have to say i don't think
that they believe
that that was 100 true there's no way on
planet earth that only two officers
would show up to a shooting double
homicide with a barricaded subject yeah
tell them to leave and like well then
let me let me just explain this from a
police perspective as well is that if
the police do a swatting call right
um and it's found to be illegitimate
right
they you know any
evidence that they think they may have
or they mean is suppressed
because this was an illegitimate entry
into a house you can enter under exigent
circumstances but if it's an
illegitimate exigent circumstance
there's no
uh searching for evidence and different
things like that so i get it but as a
cop
i see how
you can't just not do anything what's
the exergenic circumstance accident
exigent exogenous circumstances meaning
that it's a
circumstance a circumstance in which you
have to do it in a hurry it's a right
now thing that means that right now i
have to act emergency it's an emergency
i think this to me is like shows
highlights the value of local police
because when i was in chile i noticed it
was all national cops everywhere they
all have like uniforms standing on the
corner if you get a call like this yeah
but it's only national cops you got no
right no one's going to be there like
what's happening right now you know your
neighbors what's happening right now it
doesn't make sense like if if i'm a cop
and i'm hearing active shooting guy with
a gun shot two people i'm not gonna walk
in here without a swat team right yeah
well no it depends right you gotta think
of like i said excellent circumstances
police officers have a duty to respond
immediately right a swat team takes a
while to assemble i was on the swat team
and we had about an hour
if it was a full call out a hostage
situation we still had to have enough
time for everybody on the team to get
their equipment and get to the location
and we had to get together to a certain
degree to to try to uh figure out what
tactics we're gonna use so
it takes time if there was a real call
of two people shot a man with a gun they
have to respond now right and if those
two officers are the only ones in the
area they have to come now
and they have to force entry and they
have to make sure everything's okay that
that speaks to the bravery of law
enforcement officers because what if
there was a situation like that and they
were the only two here and they were
going to risk their lives potentially
getting mowed down
shot and killed ambushed right but they
had to respond anyway because there were
there was potential loss of life that
they had to rescue i've been here lately
the cops don't have to respond well the
supreme court has ruled many times if a
police officer sees a crime happening
they do not have to intervene that's an
argument that's an argument that's an
argument in the supreme court that's not
an argument that happens on the scene i
got news oh what's the news right they
entered
in direct
okay hold on i was just running around
when they came to the door they were
told you may not enter without a warrant
they said we're entering anyway oh wow
which is which is lawful exigent
circumstances right we can enter your
property and search the premises right
which is what i say i told them
with respect officers
i would like you to
you guys done you need to leave the
police officers have to check
because if they show up here and there's
a dead body in the room somewhere
because somebody just say if somebody in
the house called and said and called it
in but they actually you know did
something to themselves and the cops
just showed up and said oh there's
nothing there the next morning there's a
dead person in the house who's going to
be held liable so a quick sweep is
reasonable and then they have to leave
for future reference yes
cops ever walk in like that put on the
room cam okay very nice well it takes me
a minute to switch it over but for sure
yeah or whatever camera shows them
brandon was talking and the cops are
like walking around with flashlights and
i'm like i saw all their faces too
everyone looked oh yeah
the one copy like waves over to me and
i'm like no i'm like recording we're
live what are you doing i thought it was
a friend of yours i thought he knew you
i thought he was coming to the show
because i saw the door but i'm like
who's coming in during the podcast
well i feel bad
they were being being nice
and i understand like someone calls in
and says people are dead yeah and
they're like let's go check it out and
their their their mentality is like
we're going to be protecting tim and his
house and everything with our lives and
we don't know what's happening if you
see it was only with two of them there
were three there were no there they were
like four or five four or five yeah
because that was the upstairs guys but
when you brought up like there's no way
they wouldn't come with gear they
wouldn't be prepared i think when they
got here and realized everything was
looking normal they were like okay
let's just do a check but it seems like
a swatting right the problem i have with
it is
i don't want to blame the guy
because there's a circumstance of you
know what if someone got killed
in trouble but then the problem is what
if they can just use exigent
circumstances as of pretext to come into
my house we have we have doormats at
every door that's come back with a
warrant that's not a joke so uh allison
who uh
was downstairs they come to the door and
says you cannot come in without a
warrant and they said we are coming in
anyway we have oxygen circumstances and
then i was like because when when they
walked in here i'm like who let them in
yeah of course first of all they let
themselves in
yeah and but you got you got to
understand too is that you know they
can't they can't come here and do a
search you know say they supposed to be
searching for
uh dead bodies yeah and a crime they
come in there's no crime they leave so
they can't go snooping around they can't
go looking in the rooms
certainly they can't exist in
circumstance they will have to have to
articulate that i went and i went to
this room this room i saw the guy had a
body worn camera they can only go here
here here and leave um they can't go
snooping around your property what if
they see something illegal when they
walk around
well this is the thing like if this was
a real call and there was a real
incident that occurred and they had to
come in the house and they saw a bale of
drugs here
they have that that's that's in plain
sight they can actually
uh
come here and get the drugs and charge
somebody with it what if it's an exigent
call and they see it's the same thing
it's in plain view that's why i'm
calling bs how well we don't do anything
like that here yeah but however if it's
a swatting
none of that i don't think any of that
will hold up in the court of law if it's
a fake call to somebody's house and the
police were here and then they see
something i don't think you're to hold
up a quarterback are they going hard on
this guy that swatted
yeah that's a bit that's a felony crime
you can do like 20 years in prison for
swatting it's a it's a it's a very
serious crime i don't know i don't look
men i said it was 2022. i'm like they
are going to be going hard against
everybody you're going to be harassed
you're going to be censored you're going
to be smeared
but i don't think
i don't think the cops were involved i
think somebody i don't swallow exactly
no i'm saying whoever swatted us like
that's the pressure they want to they
want to put in the house but imagine
like what you were saying
there's a lot of people what's that book
you commit three felonies a day or
whatever yeah so there you know maybe
someone here did something dumb and then
we get swatted and the cops walk in
they're like oh look the cat's doing a
back flip on sunday that's illegal and
things like that they can't do that
that's another thing are our phone calls
exited circumstances could maybe rule
that just because someone called and
said something yeah it just depends man
like like when i was a police officer we
used to have these uh 911 hang-ups yeah
and those are the most dangerous calls
because you don't know why a person hung
up if you get enough information in this
reasonable reasonable to believe that
there could be something there you have
to check because you may get here and
two people shot and killed in a house
and a person barricading themselves is
not going to make any noise right
and this house is confusing you know so
you know you know somebody can be
somewhere and you know i know they are
i'll tell you for people who don't know
this house is a maze it's like i don't
know where i'm at it's not easier than
it was before it's not the craziest but
it's funny how people get lost here and
i don't realize i'm like wow they got
lost i've been here before and i don't
know where i'm at yeah yeah because
there's there's two different studio
rooms there's like five floors it's a
ridiculous building there's a sub
basement a basement a first second third
floor we have a new attic and uh when
you're going up to the studio there's
actually
like a fork in the road and people
usually go the wrong way and end up in
the wrong room and then they get
confused it's too dark and they're like
where's the light but that's good for me
because i was thinking about if someone
broke in here
i was like well you know when we're
going over our plan for our security
protocols because we've had these these
threats before and i and i was as i was
going through it i was like wow i just
realized
a person who comes in this house will
get lost yes because
what people need to understand is
there's a lot of people who are like
teams go to join a million dollar
american it's an office building like
the second floor is a bunch of desks and
computers for editing work one of the
bedrooms it's an equipment room with
shelves and a computer and then there's
an editing bay there's actual and then a
music studio this is a place where
people work not a place where people
live right right so that you're walking
into a 10 000 square foot office
building in the shape of a house
basically right yeah and here's here's
the silver lining in this now the police
officers know who you are
hopefully you have a conversation with
them they know what you do for a living
and now if they get another call they're
like okay slow down let me call yes
because you can give them your phone
number they'll call you and say hey we
got a call are you is everything okay
there you're like yeah they you know
it's no big deal another thing i think
would be good is to put cameras in here
so you can see what's going on well we
we do
so here can you switch can you switch to
the room cam real quick yeah hold on let
me change it so we've actually we've got
a ptz camera that can
basically sweep the whole room
uh it's it's actually pretty good look
at this so that's why we didn't
i wish we had it ready to go well no i
think i think if we knew like no one
expected cops to walk into the studio
but for future reference we see someone
let's get the camera on i have to say
they did a pretty decent job man they
nobody pulled nobody pulled a gun
yeah you know when i was a cop and we
searched houses we had our guns out
and we were you know it was pretty more
it was way more intense than that but
maybe they caught on to say oh this is
nothing going on here well we're in the
middle of nowhere yeah so when you're in
a city and you're in a house with 50
houses and hundreds of people those cops
are probably like if this person's armed
they could hurt their neighbors
we're out in the middle of nowhere
literally like it's just trees
everywhere the cops here are probably
like well if they are locked in their
house ain't going anywhere there's
nobody around them so we'll we'll get
there as fast as we can we'll check it
out it's it's less of a dire
circumstance as opposed to being a dense
population yeah somebody must have
called as if they were in the house
because that's what he said there's
because if it's an external person that
don't have current information in the
house
it's not safe for cops to just bombard
in it's better for them to make
announcements and hostages negotiate and
stuff like that but unless somebody's
bleeding out and then you got that whole
thing but whoever did it wanted it to
happen during the show wanted attention
too that's what they always did to send
the message obviously but his name is
and they're and they're probably
watching going like haha we did it but
they didn't do anything and if they get
found they're going to go to prison
fulfilling the crime i have a feeling
that they won't be found that's just my
personal perspective but sorry it's so
easy to spoof it's like
they might they might yeah you never
know with technology the way the
technology is today they got well the
nsa knows everything but they don't
share everything unless it works on
their personal benefit right plus it's
january 6th i'm like who knows
what lies what manipulations but i'm i'm
just saying
2022 men the censorship the smears the
swatting the fear tactics
the establishment does not want now i'll
say i keep telling people vote in the
primaries oh you have to local and in
the prime minister that is the scariest
thing because that's their secret the
republicans and the democrats know that
their worst case scenario for the most
part is even if they vote for the other
the other you know party
we we're we're winning the primaries and
the establishment will still be in power
so when we come out on our shows your
show our show whatever show we say vote
in the primaries they're like oh that's
the secret that's where you actually can
get rid of the neocons and the neolibs
that's where change over you don't have
to wait four years you can get them in
the primary and make sure you vote local
you know we a lot of people are are so
worried about these federal elections
that they are
the leftists are taking over
in local elections they're taking over
the school board they're taking over all
of these local elections city council
and they're running the city from within
you may have a republican senator but
the state level politicians are all
democrats and so then when election time
comes around and things like that
who's monitoring that it's going to be
the people that's on a state level and
so i think that we need to vote in and
out of season like you have to vote you
have to get involved you have to be a
part of the process you know me and my
wife we made it a promise this year that
we're going to be more a part of the
process we can't just sit back and just
talk we got to be we got to know what's
going on we got to endorse the right
candidates we have to support candidates
fund them if we can we have to be active
or we're going to get steamrolled just
really quick because a lot of people are
asking in the comment section everyone's
fine everyone's safe i'm talking to
people on the house on the phone every
animal's safe nothing happened luckily
we were able to avoid anyone getting
seriously hurt um so we were very lucky
and everyone's okay and everyone's safe
but i i was i was you know after you
mentioned like why would they just come
two guys i was like i need to go tell
them to get out like because they were
they were when i when i talked to them
they were like we're we're going to go
or whatever and then i thought no i need
to i need to see them at the door i need
to make sure that i say to them i don't
want them here i don't approve of them
being here i don't approve of any
searches and they didn't do any
extensive kind of searching just walked
through the house and walked out and
then when i went down i was like who let
them in
and every people were like no actually
we denied them entry and so i'm like all
right you know i think we did the best
we could do in the circumstances kind of
feels like an inoculation like they're
like okay we know tim they know us that
some of the cops watched the show in the
town i said that uh i've been told
andreas told me once that one of the
cops he met a cop and he was like yeah i
watched the show it's awesome i think i
think they're familiar yeah they know
that they that there's going to be
efforts this is the challenge this is
the challenge with cops i feel i feel uh
i empathize with them especially if
they're keeping us safe in the event
some like some lunatic could actually
come here and then make that phone call
and they're going to be like what if it
literally is some crazy
psychopath wants to go and and screw up
the show and hurt people right we need
their help we do yeah so the one time
they do come in i don't want to be the
boy who cried wolf next time something
bad happens i'm like guys no for real
this is me and this is happening they're
going to be like yeah yeah yeah yeah
we're not falling for that again and you
don't want to be a jerk i don't want it
to happen you don't want to be a jerk to
him either i i think that that wouldn't
matter they'll still save your life but
you don't want to be a jerk to them it's
it's a communication is the best thing
that's that's the hard time i think
communication is the best thing i would
you know have an opportunity to get the
officer's badge number get communication
with the officers and set up a
contingency plan and say look this is
what we do here this is where i'm
located
you know if we have an incident can we
have a secret code where like if we call
something in we only we know a certain
passphrase they just look it's hard to
get through the dispatch like that but
you but they could put
like because you're on our system and i
think the system is probably generally
the same across the board
your address has a flag on it right so
in the system it'll say that this house
was swatted they could write that down
in the system they could say this person
is a podcast or they can have a special
note for this address so therefore when
a call comes in to the dispatch the
dispatch runs the address and the
address has a flag on it and they go
okay they'll tell the officers this
person is a podcaster we've been there
before for swatting um you know here's
this here's the person's phone number so
an officer can try to contact a contact
here first before they show up and it
becomes violent if they contact the
contact here you say no it's real deal
like we're we need your help you know
it's better to have relationships with
police than to leave it up to chance
because it could go south and we don't
want to be on opposite we had to do this
with the last place we lived at so those
cops were awesome and i went to the
department we talked politics and we had
a laugh and yeah and i told them like
just so you guys know like we're like a
block away
so i just want to say like the what i
was trying to convey is you know and i
was like with respect you know i
understand why you guys are here but i
would appreciate if you would leave i
don't approve of any search with you
unless you have a warrant and they were
like okay all right you know we get it
and the truth is they probably
just imagine if they found something in
here you know how long an investigation
will take no cop wants to do that they
don't want nothing to do with this
they don't even want to be here like i
mean the average cop would be like okay
yeah tell me twice you good we good i'm
getting out of here i'm ready to go
this is one of the reasons why we're
moving to west virginia too yeah um i
don't trust maryland's laws on
self-defense i don't trust this state
and while i live in west virginia we set
up you know production right on the side
of the river which is in maryland
so
there's the one thing that concerns me
is or that i find disconcerting and just
does concern me and everybody here
actually
if this is a if this is you know if
you're going to raid somewhere if you're
going to hurt someone the smartest thing
an evil person would do is swat us you
know why
get the cops to relax get them to think
oh it's just a swatting so the next time
this happens they get a report of
something crazy going on they're going
to be like let's slow down guys it's
probably bs and it gives the bad guy
more time right and if they're targeting
us they know that so you know we're
armed here um but we are limited to a
certain degree based on what maryland
does allow but maryland allows enough
i'll put it that way more than enough
west virginia allows way more yeah
that's why i live in arizona
constitutional carrier i got all kind of
stuff and i got it everywhere so
somebody come in my house it'll be like
fourth of july it's gonna be a light
show are you on really good terms with
the cops in the area oh yeah they know
me they fought all of them followed me
on social media you know uh so if they
know me you know the funny thing is my
lawn went off and my son didn't know the
code to disarm it and the long goes off
man the cops show up thinking it's a
burglary call
and uh they end up seeing me at the
front door and they're like officer
tatum
so i'm like yo put this address down
this is where i live so just in case
something happened you know it's me do
you get down with the fire department
too do you hang out with the firemen oh
i know yeah my best friend is a
firefighter in in the phoenix valley and
uh yeah we cool my dad was a firefighter
oh yeah me too my dad retired he was uh
he retired as a chief of wayco fire
nice yeah so yeah oh yeah we used to
have like environment police picnics and
stuff yeah we talk trash every day of
course
i call them the second responders
oh yeah hey what's this book behind you
we didn't haven't mentioned it yet i've
been looking at it throughout the show
my book beating black and blue being a
black cop in america under siege
i wrote a book about policing in america
this very thing you know trying to
make sure that there's education on
policing in america with the defunded
police movement with police brutality
what's a justified shooting what's not i
interviewed five police officers in the
book um to give their experiences of
what it's like being a police officer
today you know in society today with all
the craziness that's going on and at the
end of the book we give solutions so
that's one of the one of my prouder
moments of 2021 was publishing where's
the best place for people to get it uh
amazon cool i said you go on amazon
being black and blue put it in there and
it was when i launched it was number one
bestseller
um i have a question number one new
release
do you think we should make robot cops
no
it's something about personal
relationships
it's something about human human
interaction
you don't want the cops to be letter of
the law
you want them to be letter lettering
spirit of the law and like those cops
that came here you know they have
emotions and you know maybe they can
perceptualize things a little better
than a computer would but you do want to
connect you know i think it's invaluable
for community policing and
community policing to be a part of
policing in
in the community you know the the bond
together um because
if we had the adequate amount of police
officers we funded our police officers
like we should we would have so many
more
productive relationships and because
police aren't bad
they are not
inherently bad it's just and what they
do is not bad it's just that
it's such a big communist communication
what about the cops in new york city and
other major areas that are enforcing
lockdowns and shutting down small
businesses while they allow walmart and
amazon to be open well you got to think
of it like this you say who's bad the
officer that's doing it or the system or
the governor or the mayor but they
wouldn't be able to do it without the
officers orders no no no but this is i'm
an individualist i'm not a collectivist
right so this is the way this is the way
i look at it i say let's come let's make
sure we're talking about the same thing
if an officer is arresting a person for
trespassing because a private business
has rights i'm cool with that i don't
believe it's right that a municipality
enforces
mandates on on shutting down a business
now i don't know the nuances i don't
know what leveraged police officers have
are they just giving tickets are they
forcing people out what are they
actually doing i don't know they're
putting people in camps in australia but
that's australia that's not here so i
don't agree with what's happening there
in new york city here an unvaxed guy
walks into a burger king and they say
you can't order you if unless you have
your vax card you got to leave he says
no i want to be served they say you're
trespassing the cops come in yeah the
cops say you're trespassing now and
we're going to arrest you but the only
reason they're trespassing is because
they're unvaccinated no not well you got
to think from the police perspective
you're right according to the business
but according to the police it doesn't
matter what the what the business is
doing it's just a matter are you have
you been asked a reasonable request to
leave it just seems like the cops
enforcing vaccination with extra steps
no no i don't think the cops have
anything to do with that you know the
cops are responding because a business
asks the person to leave and they refuse
to this could be
mass mandate
but the businesses want you to leave the
business wants you to buy a cheeseburger
no but they want you to leave they don't
so
a lot of these businesses will straight
up say like we're not the ones doing
this the city's making us so if the
police if the police are enforcers of
the state and the stasis state is
telling the business you better kick
them out otherwise we'll punish you
then you can't go back to the state and
be like okay now kick them out but it's
not your fault because you're a
different state actor no no it's the
state well no i understand but we have
laws that we voted on and so if we want
things to change we need to change those
laws we need to change the power that we
give governors and mayors but it's
decrees it's not even lost
it's politicians saying i decree your
small business gets shut down and police
officers come and find you and steal
your wealth and steal your business
license and make you shut down while
we're going to allow all these other big
corporations to be open and this is
because i said so and cops are like yep
got it
what do you want the cops to do say no
say no this is this is a decree this is
not a law this wasn't passed
democratically this wasn't something
that we agreed upon through our system
you're going above and beyond the system
you're abusing your power you could only
enforce this power if i do it so i'm
going to say no i'm going to hold myself
responsible to the letter of the law i
want to believe you i want i want to go
down that path with you i agree to a
certain degree but at the same time
there's laws on the book so if the
you've given the mayor the governor's
power to enforce certain things you may
disagree with them it's not up to the
police officer to say i agree i disagree
the police officer is supposed to act on
what is the actual law what authority do
the mayor or the governor have according
to the law now if you're violating the
law in the constitution then i would
agree that police officers should not uh
participate in that
if it's got to be obvious it can't be
anybody say i live in new jersey okay
and i take my uh 30 30 winchester
repeater honest on a sling and i walk
down the street and a cop walks up and
says felony you're going to prison and
arrest me is that cop wrong to do that
i'm not i'm not sure what's the law
well the constitution says i have the
right to keep and bear arms right so
this is this is the this is the problem
with with us voting for certain things
well you can't vote away my
constitutional rights there but we have
it and we have accepted it they're
inalienable no no no no no no hold on
hold on let me let me see all of us
haven't no no if a person now i know a
lot of us say i would never vote for
uh gun restriction at all but the way we
have our system is that maybe people
don't agree but the majority voted and
that's how it gets that's the point of
the constitution right but this is what
i'm saying to prevent i agree with you
just certain to a certain degree
i wish we didn't have any of those
things in but we're inc inconsistent
with the way we apply these things if a
person murdered 20 people went to prison
for 20 years got out
and they're a prohibited possessor is
that right i think the answer is no but
wow so i'm saying but we like we as a
society we've accepted that well
the constitution is reasonable as uh so
that there there's there's been a few uh
uh instances of evolution on my position
first was i was like no i think if you
do your time you get your guns back and
then people correctly noted that the
constitution
your rights can be curtailed through due
process which means if you are a violent
felon part of due process is you can no
longer have a weapon that is
constitutional and i said actually yeah
that that actually is true it's in the
constitution right but for a 60 year old
woman to have a snub nose you know 38 or
something and for a cop to be like she
belongs in prison but i don't care what
the constitution says
but a cop you got to think a cop doesn't
make that decision that decision is made
in the court of law no no no no no
has discretion a cop has discretion how
he wants to enforce the laws no no you
don't he has discretion the supreme
court's actually ruled on this okay no
no
an officer
okay just say this person murdered
another person can an officer walk up
and say i'm not arresting you because i
don't want to arrest you you murdered a
pedophile so i'm not going to arrest you
you don't it's certain things you have
discretion on and certain things you
don't have discretion on
right a speeding ticket a speeding
ticket you can have a discretion on
criminal criminal law no no you you to
enforce that law there was a really big
story in new york that luke was covered
and interviewed the guy the supreme
court i think it was right the supreme
court actually said the cops have no
obligation to enforce the law that's not
yeah but that's not applied on the
street level that's applied well it's a
choice no no that's applied when you
have to challenge these things in the
court of law that's not applied on the
street well my friend joe lozito was
attacked by a serial
murderer who was on a killing spree he
was able to stop him police officers
were watching the whole time standing by
looking as the whole thing happened the
police officers knew that there was a
serial killer on their loose they saw
him attack kill people they saw him
stabbing people police officers with
firearms with batons two of them decided
to stand behind and hide and not be seen
as joe lozito a man who is a hero who
stopped a mass murderer he used
techniques that he saw on the ufc took
him down disabled his knife after being
stabbed in the head almost losing his
life and after that only after the knife
was was thrown away after this this this
killer was was finally subdued then the
police officers came out put handcuffs
on him and they waited a long time joe
lazida almost bled out because of that
long wait and then on the national news
they had police officers save man from
serial killer calling him a victim which
was an utter disgrace joe lizzito sued
the police officer said how am i a
victim when i stopped this guy and these
cops were just watching sitting there on
their hands not doing anything who was
considered the victim joe lozito the the
guy who took him down the guy who almost
lost his life the guy who almost bled
out because the police officers were
waiting to get back up even though they
hadn't subdued and handcuffed and and
joe lozito sued the nypd saying you you
spurs my name you lied about me you
didn't help me you were watching me
getting stabbed and the police officers
argued we have no duty to protect and
serve you and the court in new york
upheld that ruling are those officers
still on on duty yeah they were promoted
by mayor michael bloomberg so they were
seen as heroes by the corporate media
right let me this is this is one thing
i'll have to do i can't speak to that
that sounds like the craziest thing i've
ever heard i've never heard of a case
like that now yeah i'll take your word
for it i have to look at it no no no no
i did a whole video about this i'll send
you i'll send it i'll let you even talk
about this if you want to i will have to
i'll have to watch it and go through
before i i can't i could i have never in
my life saw a police officer or even
heard of a police officer in any of the
connective um agencies that we've been a
part of we train with that will ever
use that as a measuring stick of how
they enforce law or how they participate
in saving and protecting people
and on my department there was a a a
order
that's called cowardice you cannot show
cowardice you would be fired it doesn't
matter what the constitution say well
so you know so i'm saying if they end up
in a constitutional law maybe they'll
determine it have you ever have you ever
seen a uh when you're an officer have
you ever have you or are you uh ever
witnessed have you ever witnessed or
have you
seen someone with say an illegal amount
of pot and been like get out of here kid
i don't care about that i've never done
that but do you have you seen other cops
i've heard of cops doing that i've i i
know of cops i do in chicago all the
time i also know that when i was
arrested because i me and my brother got
attacked physically and
i tried calling 9-1-1 the guy's
attacking us turned my phone off and
then called the cops on us and when the
cops showed up i said we've got evidence
they attacked us i don't care
i can't do a cross-complaint they're not
getting arrested the police have a right
to choose what they decide yeah and
is called probable cause so a police
can't
this is the thing like
if a police officer sees a crime
committed he has to act on that crime
you're sworn to do that
up to hold the conservation in the law
and the constitution says you have right
to keep embarrassment no yeah i
understand it so they're not doing that
i agree with what you're saying but we
have laws on the books like you just
explained a person who is a felon who
murdered 20 people or something let me
let me give you better now you get out
of prison what i'm saying a felon gets
out of prison and on his record he's a
prohibited possessor a cop catches him
going into a school with a gun in his
pocket they're going to arrest them for
illegally being in a legal politic
position
how about the the jewish schools in new
york which have a first amendment right
to practice their religion and the cops
were going and filming them and then
finding people and welding uh uh uh
welding the parks closer
how about when they were going to
churches and synagogues and telling
people you're not allowed to worship
that that is they're they're not
upholding their oath of the constitution
now i want to make sure there's a
distinction here when we were in the
philly suburbs our suburb cops were
fantastic we didn't deal with that
because when you when you have a smaller
department and these people are these
cops are members of the community things
seem to work a whole lot better than
when you have a large heavily dense area
where the cops don't know you and don't
care about you but every day in new york
city they violate the constitution
outright yeah so there's no question and
i'm not disagreeing i'm not disagreeing
with that but here's the here's the
nuance that i see in this and i think
people should think about this for a
minute
you know there's people that actually
believe that if you don't put on a mask
that you're killing people
just imagine if this was the swine flu
or ebola
would it be out of the ordinary
for governors to mandate that there's a
curfew if ebola was out and people were
dying in mass amounts because they
weren't protecting them because they
were crowded in places i think most
people would be like okay that makes
sense if the businesses were shut down
and they said you cannot open up
business because ebola is spreading
everywhere you have to shut this down
if
in fact that was the case many people
would not argue the constitutionality of
a governor doing that but that's a
hypothetical that wasn't the case no no
no no hold on think about that for two
seconds
people would willingly be like you are
right i won't open my business they
don't need a government to tell them to
do it when they're watching hemorrhagic
fever kill people no but what i'm saying
is that the governor has the power
to
enforce these things or to order these
things in an emergency situation the
power that we gave governors to do in an
emergency the difference is
we at least i don't believe that this is
ebola
i don't believe we should be doing any
of this right this is my belief however
there are people on the spectrum that
are that believe wholeheartedly that if
you don't have two of them on your face
that you're gonna kill people and people
are dying and overloading the hospitals
and so governors in new york and
governors in some of these left-wing
areas are enforcing
decreased things not by law
and also governors in arizona and in in
florida are not i want to i want to
mention just based off what we just went
through with these with getting swatted
and it wasn't the most intense swat team
didn't kick our door and a bunch of cops
just came in we said no and they swept
the property
i i think if more leftists understood
what this is like it would be a very
very very important thing for them to
like to understand
these cops were not mean to us they came
in we didn't want them to
we do have fears about people breaking
in here and we do
talk to the cops and we've had we have
talked to the cops uh just about um
we've had we've had issues in the past
we call the cops and talk to them and so
i'm sitting here as like
i don't necessarily trust them to come
in here without a warrant i don't know
what they're doing or why i you know
every lawyer worth their worth their
weight will tell you don't talk to cops
but i also appreciate that they just
tried to save our lives that someone
called them and said tim poole's you
know house
workspace people are dead there and
these cops rushed in and said out of my
way there could be people heard here it
could have been me these these cops were
like i don't care who you are what
you're saying for all they know antifa
or some crackpot you know conspiracy
person
broke in here with their friends heard
us and now they're standing there saying
don't worry officer everything's fine
you don't need to come in you have a
warrant and the cops are going to be
like i don't care what you say if we get
a report about this so it's it's it's a
difficult position right yeah and
they're willing to die for you it's not
they're not willing to show up here just
to do a a patty cake with you they're
willing to die man cops are dying every
day in a situation like this and they
don't they didn't i don't believe they
batted an eye they came up here and they
was willing to die
for the sake of you and anybody else in
this in this building and the same
people that we are saying in some of
these cases you see in new york where
they're questionable about their
enforcement and some of these laws they
are the same ones that are still out
protecting people with their lives every
day and getting murdered so i i want us
to balance the perspective here we may
disagree and i think these things will
find their way out in court because it's
not very clear if this is a violation of
the constitution at least the
the
private business is saying you have to
show a vaccination card experiencing
this i think is good for the left and
the right i think there you know a lot
of the perspective on policing is that
people on the left who are in big cities
deal with cops all the time and people
who are in rural areas don't really deal
with cops all that all the time they
might see him in passing but they
probably know know the officers there's
there's there's there's very few
so for me i'm just saying you know we
have someone mentioned that you're
wearing a do not comply shirt but you're
also defending cops it's because i'm a
smart i'm smart enough to know that
there's nuances that's exactly like do
not comply with tyranny but you need to
like like this that's like saying george
floyd should george floyd have complied
yeah i mean yeah i think he would have
never been under the guys knee if he
would have should you know any of these
people who are running from the police
should they have comply yes just because
i have a do not comply shirt don't mean
i'm telling you do not comply with a
lawful order right right
so but people are too
ignorant to understand that there's well
some people this is why some people not
everybody this is the point i'm trying
to get across like i'm torn on this one
i'm not left i'm not right i'm not
anti-cup i'm not pro cop
i'm worried the police can use these
this is a pretext to enter my home
without a warrant and and mess with me
i'm also worried that we've got very
serious security threats we've got a
security system installed we've had
multiple security companies come out
where we're in the process of onboarding
some security people and these cops are
willing to come in here rush in to save
us
so it's like
it's it's basically do you trust them or
not it's a difficult position i think
it's fair to say you can trust them
because you also got to understand
they're only one part of the justice
system they can come in here and if you
believe they did something unlawful
there's a process to that they they they
are not going to convict you in the
court of law the police can't they can
arrest you based on probable cause but
then you have an opportunity to defend
yourself in a court of law just like if
they came in here and they found
something illegal
that's going to be a legal battle in the
court of law that i'm not sure if you
can you can fight that forgot bad news
for the conspiracy theorists it's a very
it might look fun on tv but it's
relatively
we've got like a skee-ball machine we've
got cameras
that the room behind us is a bunch of
editing
and and like coding came out yesterday
it was silent i was like wow yeah we've
got a kitchen
uh it's it's nothing crazy going on here
but there are conspiracy theorists who
say crazy stuff about what happens
and and it's funny because people are
like tim pools building a compound i'm
like with an office building it's a
house yeah i mean there always should be
a middle ground and i do believe trust
should be earned i mean me and tim also
had very negative experiences with
police officers in chicago that were
literally trying to set us up and put a
gun to my head because of journalism
that we were doing uh during events that
was absolutely not warranted uh so
there's a number of these events and
then there's a number of these things so
anytime you have power you should have
some kind of transparency and
accountability and i think you could
have a level-headedness when you have
that but i think a lot of people you
know there's some good officers out
there and there's some bad officers out
there when they have that power and it's
not accounted for and there's nothing uh
holding them responsible for a lot of
the kind of egregious actions that's
when a lot of people have a lot of
serious questions now again you
shouldn't go overboard and just think
that all cops are horrible or all cops
are great i think the middle ground here
is important and understanding personal
responsibility and understanding you're
responsible for yourself is some of the
things that i think we should be
preaching about and talking about more
than that and most cops
are good cops most cops are good people
the police system in and of itself is
reasonable
it's not easy to do the things that
people think is easy to do
like you say most people don't interact
with cops you just it's impossible even
if you're in new york you know i mean
people living new how many people live
in new york eight million or something
like that yeah some there's there's one
or two cops for every thousand person
the cops are not interacting with
everybody they only really interact with
about 20 of the population and they
interact with about 15 to 5 percent of 5
of the population all the time it's the
same group of people that are out here
doing crime all the time so most people
aren't really interacting with police
and so i i just think people are
they may be feeling some type of way
there's an emotional charge to it i
understand that but we have to like i
said you have to put it in perspective
the same offices where people are saying
you are
enacting tyranny
as soon as they walk away from this call
they are out here protecting the servant
with their lives and so you have to
understand
they're not just acting in one role you
may disagree with this aspect of it but
you have to understand the whole story
like why does the governor have the
power to do these things in the first
place why does the government how can
the governor tell you you can shut down
your business i think the cop is like a
by-product you should be protesting a
governor you should be protesting the
mayor the cops are a byproduct of
something that's ambiguous but but the
the governor wouldn't be there if it
wasn't for the cops enforcing these
unconstitutional edicts and decrees and
they have to understand
they're getting guidance from the
governor exactly the guidance is is not
legal lee's language i mean that's the
same argument that a lot of germans were
making during world war ii saying i was
just following orders i was just doing
what we're told and a lot of atrocities
this is my comparison but this is i'm
historical context to a lot of human
atrocities that have happened because
people saying i follow orders world war
ii is overused too many times but when
we look at human history a lot of pain a
lot of suffering a lot of death resulted
to men saying you tell me to do it i'm
going to do it without even thinking
about it what i would personally would
love to see is a little bit of more
discernment a little bit more upkeeping
to the letter of the law instead of just
saying this guy told me to do it i'm
going to do it because so many human
atrocities have happened and i think
we're very close for them happening now
especially with what's happening in
australia what's happening in europe
what's happening in canada that could
come here if enough officers say i will
follow that order without questioning it
okay look this is the thing it's not
like the governor says officer you go do
this it comes down from the city council
command staff and guidance that's given
to the officers through the lieutenants
the captains the chiefs i mean the
sergeants these are protocols that are
disseminated down through officers and
also many of these police departments
have legal advisors we were a small
police department we had a legal adviser
they would advise us what can you do
legally
according to the constitution according
to laws where the department doesn't get
sued so i think it's a bunch of minutia
that comes down through the pike
and people have power that shouldn't
have power in the way they do and now
the police are taking a fall for it but
they wouldn't have power if police
officers weren't doing what they were
told to do by them right if they could
understand that if there was a little
bit more discernment if they were like
saying hey hey hey maybe we shouldn't as
walmart's open and people are giving all
of their money so that maybe we
shouldn't
you know we shouldn't stop by this poor
grandma's house and shut down her
business in new jersey maybe we just
shouldn't do that personally ourselves
because of the larger implications
and that kind of discernment is all i'm
asking for because it makes more sense
than to just follow a decree that hurts
everyone overall and destroys people's
income and destroyed people's
livelihoods because they were just
following orders right but you feel that
way but some people don't feel that way
some people don't feel so the grandma
deserves to have her business shut down
some people believe that she does if
she's not do you think she does i don't
think she does okay but i think but she
only does because officers said yes no
not the officers it's because the
governor has made an order that is
deeming this behavior that is going to
cause people to die and contagion from
this dr this virus is going to spread
everywhere if people don't shut down and
quarantine it that's it's a it's a
nuance now let me let me talk about it
like this
some people believe that marijuana
should be illegal
some people believe marijuana should be
legal
so do cops use the discretion in that
and say well i don't think people should
go to jail for marijuana so i'm not
going to arrest you for marijuana but
then the cop over here says i hate
marijuana my kids have gotten in the
drug game and i want marijuana to stop
in my community so i'm going to enforce
it just like the mandates there's a
wacky cop out here that believe that
they need to wear three masks and they
believe that everybody's dying like cnn
is saying should they over enforce
grandma
and the guys who say you know this is
not even a real thing should they not do
anything the the the point is that cops
should follow the letter of the law and
i believe that this is ambiguous though
i think this is ambiguous i believe that
we're going to come to a place where we
find out that they should have never
done this according to the constitution
just really quick but we agree on super
chat but just really quick we agree what
happened to grandma was wrong you're
saying it's it's the governor's fault
i'm saying it's the mechanics of the
whole how the system worked i think
she's wrong some people think that it's
right that they i wanna say but we agree
but we at least agree what happened to
grandma with the lock we got absolutely
right i think it's wrong okay i want to
shut down no business i want to have i
want to have a conversation about this
but let's do the members segment where
we can get more in depth and we got to
do super chats too so i want to make
sure we can we have a ton of super chats
now pouring in in light of uh recent
events let me just tell you guys like we
have a whole bunch of stories we had uh
um
djokovic the the tennis player in
australia oh yeah didn't get to any of
it because cops walk in the middle of
the show
i get up and i'm like running downstairs
what's going on and so it's topical
though brandon's here with uh i know
that police officer well this led to an
interesting conversation and debate
which i found civil and and eye-opening
for the general public i think there's a
lot of points i want to make too but we
should get to the super chats because
otherwise we'll go a little bit a little
uh uh
we'll go too long and some people want
to talk about civil asset forfeiture and
all stuff so
we'll have a lot to talk about that
member segment for the time being smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel where the next time we get
swatted we have a room a room camera
that will show you the police walking in
i'm actually really surprised like you
know i'm like i see the cops walking
we're all looking at each other luke you
were talking yeah i was talking i'm like
i looked up one of his eyes
i thought it was a friend of yours that
just came in to say hi and he was like
oh i'm sorry
who is that yeah he's trying to guess
he was a cop he's like wearing a body
armor and a uniform yeah he had a body
camera on and i was like
yo what else that just seems to be a
little more than i want that body camera
footage maybe we can put on the website
oh yeah you should get it you can for
you requested oh yeah oh cool do you
think they might just give it to us
right away though yeah it's not a crime
it's not a crime deal coming so there's
no investigation it needs to be well
kind of but it's not like a murder where
they have to go through
they probably wrote a report which we
need to know all the details about which
we should uh
do that immediately you have a right to
obtain the 9-1-1 call so you get like
let's get the 9-1-1 call
because we might recognize the voice
because we might know exactly who did
this so let's let's make sure we're on
that asap all right let's read some
super chats we got hendrick here he says
are you aware that the mexican state of
baja california enacted nyc style proof
of jab requirements in order to enter
private businesses
i did not but that's absolutely
ridiculous the president of mexico has
made very strong statements against the
mandates against the lockdowns and uh it
looks like some people are acting
totally differently on that specific
section of mexico which is very strange
because
again the president of mexico made very
strong statements against big pharma
which i absolutely agreed with and uh to
see this happening in mexico is kind of
sad
so a lot of people have super chat that
apparently uh tucker carlson had ted
cruz on did you see this
i'm seeing yeah people are chatting that
he's getting slam dunk and he was like
it was a mistake i shouldn't have said
it was an accident and tucker is like
you're a liar wow awesome man he's even
more of a punk
yeah i know right
to it dude you said it fess up to it all
right brent saigan says hey tim not sure
if you remember but you helped bully my
brother grant a few months ago into
getting an account with tim kest anyways
it's my 21st birthday today so that's
fun wishing you all the best also have
luke say my last name it's polish what
is it how do you say c-y-g-a-n
most polish is just like
it's like bees
backwards are
[Music]
all right some of these uh we had one
but i think it might be a little too
vague happy birthday man by the way yes
happy birthday thank you oh yeah
shout out to brandon absolutely
all right group b says ron desantis had
a press conference today brought the
fact the media keeps insinuating an
insurrection took place but after one
year no one has been charged with
insurrection
that's the scary part this is the part
that i feel like is is balancing in that
constitutional thing why are people
still detained if nobody's been charged
how long can you lawfully detain
somebody
for something that they haven't it's
like due process i mean you would think
that you would now i could be wrong
because the letter of the law may say
something different and this is a caveat
that we are getting exposed to but you
can't detain somebody in for a period
longer than reasonable before they have
due process and have their atomic courts
but these people i guess have been in a
hole for
a year now i'll be honest i haven't read
the the national defense authorization
act or the patriot act in full but i
think well there's different ones the
impetus is that you're allowed to
indefinitely detain someone if they're
suspected of terrorism there's a
provision in within that yeah yeah but
which which is a problem because you see
trump came out and he came out against
these people in january 6. all these
politicians who are coming out against
people january 6 are responsible and to
a certain degree of the reason why these
people are still down there being
detained when a lot of them didn't even
i mean i don't think that they did any
violence there's no evidence well i mean
i can't say that no evidence
there are people who engaged in violence
which i saw
but
a lot of these people were
the doors were open the cops were taking
selfies with them right and now they're
being they're getting months in in jail
you know and i've been in jail for some
people for solitary for like eight was
it now it's a year almost yeah and i
think that i mean that's why i didn't go
down there
i was upset about it but i didn't go
down there because i know what the law
is you can't just storm the capitol in
in our country you just can't it's also
meaningless like what do they think was
gonna happen yeah you're gonna storm and
do what yeah
y'all have nothing to do you're not
gonna do anything so what's the point of
doing it i don't think that they should
be held in detention but
the law is the law man if you want to
take it there you got to take it there
and receive the uh what's going to come
after it just like martin luther king
when they did sit-ins they got arrested
i took that i want to argue more because
lawful does not mean moral and a lot of
atrocities in this world and throughout
history war lawful we'll get into that
but we'll talk about that later that's
actually a really good point i want to
talk about we got to hear from gunner he
says i'm gen z and my generation is
stupid there are probably other zoomers
here that would agree with me it's such
blatant idiocracy that's becoming more
surreal it's exactly what they wanted i
think gunner i think you're you're right
but it's not as bad as you think
a pew research poll found that gen z is
actually the first generation in 100
years to be slightly more conservative
than the previous generation what's the
age of gen z uh what are they like 90
was it like 95 yeah born in 95 and up or
something like that so i'll i'll just
say this uh so gen z actually could be
fair you know fairly old like late 20s
at this point
uh millennials are more active online
and they're protected online i'm sorry
i'm sorry um woke people so be it gen z
or millennials they're more likely in my
opinion to be active on the internet to
be protected when they say insane things
and the corporate media protects them
and puts out their message so that's why
they try to censor that's why they try
to hide dislike dislike accounts they
want you to think you're alone they want
you to think that they're the majority
when they are not seriously look up the
pew research study that talks about the
political leanings of generations and
while gen z is almost identical to
millennials in terms of their political
positioning they're in some areas
slightly to the right like a tiny bit
but that is huge because throughout the
past several generations it always flows
left and the left has been very proud of
that something changed and i think it
has to do with um uh parenting and and
child rearing conservatives were more
likely to have kids in the tooth in the
early 2000s so that means 22 year olds
today 21 year olds there's going to be
more conservatives than liberals because
liberals were having 1.5 kids and
conservatives were having 2.01 kids i
did this whole thing researching the
birthing rates in the year 2000. so
there you go born in the year 2000 22
years old today
that's crazy we are very old people
we're going to be farting dust soon yeah
farting dust man uh all right let's see
let's try and grab another uh we have so
many super chats i'm sorry we can't we
can't get to all of them very exciting
night what's up guys all right um you
know what i'm reading this one moneybag
says tim have you looked into flat or
convex earth
very thought-provoking that it'd be
awesome to have eric dube or dave weiss
on elite lie why not on on this um i've
i've certainly read a lot of the flat
earth stuff and i find it funny and wow
just i'm sorry man the earth is not flat
ian where are you on this i want to know
where ian stands i used to think of
earth as a sphere now i think of it more
as kind of an amorphous bubble that's
kind of changing shape like the sun if
you look at it with the telescope it's
kind of bubbulous um that i like this
convex earth that it's maybe it's like a
a discus that's kind of pulsing like
that kind of ovular the convex earth
theory is that the earth is a bowl
i don't go that far i don't think that
there's any flat i think that comes from
ancient history like ancient stories and
now people are kind of getting a jive
out of bringing it back and i gotta stop
you on this fear thing the reason i find
this all ridiculous is that we've known
this for for a millennia the earth is on
the back of a giant turtle yeah drifting
through space
obviously
[Laughter]
the earth is like a little wart on
somebody i watched i watched one guy who
said like he went on a plane with a
leveler and then he was like
if the earth is round then the plane
should dip down to go with the curvature
which means the leveler will change and
then he like time lapses it's like see
it didn't and it's just like ah
yeah i don't know if the plane would do
that it would just stay
just coast around like this but he
thought that the plane would go to the
edge of the earth and then have to have
to turn down have to like actually go
down because gravity doesn't work
for something
some guy said that the world you know
like if i said if the earth stopped
people would continue to fly at like
thousands of miles per hour i'm going to
have
dreams about a couple hundred miles
talking about this tonight by the way
yeah that's weird i mean i wonder what's
the obsession with flat earth like i
mean i don't get it like who cares i
think it's another form of psychosis
like does it matter i'm not it's
interesting to talk about anything but
yeah that people are like latching onto
weird weird stuff like that like that's
a weird one talk about 911 cool let's
talk about facts but that's like i don't
know i've never seen any evidence for it
yeah all right let's read some more we
got razon he says get badge numbers file
a police report reach out tell me how to
reach out to y'all in my infoset company
help you find who made that call cheers
and thank god y'all are okay yeah my
phone's been blowing up we i tweeted out
as soon as it happened a lot of people
were watching when it happened and you
know everybody's fine it was i it wasn't
the apocalypse some like swatting some
like often is like they're in suits and
they've got rifles and they're like
everybody on the ground
police departments have have grown from
that when i was when i was a police
officer they we went through training
about swatting we're also in the middle
of nowhere yeah so they're probably like
they don't probably have a swat team
around here yeah they don't and but not
only
they're probably thinking if some dude's
in his shack and did do this
like
we have time yeah we have time there's
nobody around you know sometimes i wake
up in the morning i hear gunshots going
off and i'm just like sipping my coffee
and i'm like
yeah like the neighbor is shooting again
it's not chicago yeah i know
well you do hear gunshots
in chicago when i'm when i'm growing up
in a kid and i hear gunshots and i'm
sitting there sipping my coffee i'm like
oh the gangs are shooting each other
again
and then a bullet come through your
coffee mug it shatters and you're like i
got a new mug um but for for different
reasons we we don't care yeah sometimes
we hear like it sounds almost like full
auto because so many people are shooting
bangs in the distance and the birds fly
away the sound of freedom man that's why
i think the cops are probably like
some you know something did happen yeah
you know they didn't seem to he's not
right he's not going anywhere they
didn't seem too intense when they came
here they were kind of like lost a
little bit i'm pretty sure they were
lofty they didn't know where they were
at the one cop like fanned me over and i
was just like i was like nope
like we got cameras on and live and i'm
like this is the worst possible time to
do something like this but i had no idea
what it was about yeah you know i knew
it was right away but when i knew you
didn't know him i said somebody must
have swallowed it yeah oh man luckily i
got a message that everything was fine
as soon as everything was going down so
well when i talked to the crew everybody
did everything right so i'm really i'm
really proud of the team but people
didn't understand i tweeted this this
isn't this is like an office so there's
like what a dozen employees here right
now it's not a house see if it i mean it
is a house but like when you walk in
you're like oh it's an office you know
what i mean yeah you can clearly see
that this is what you do here but so
if this was like a small house if people
if if you this is the crazy thing like
imagine the daily wire got swatted like
they show up to this big building
they're gonna be like
knock on the door and there's a
receptionist and you're like we have a
receptionist too so i'm sure they show
up and they're just like there's all
these employees all over the place
there's the work going on there
as soon as they saw that they're
probably okay
yeah normally what they would do is they
would call
if it's during the daytime they will
call the dispatcher will call the number
for daily wire and say
you guys experience an emergency there
and then they'll be done with it all
right luke's mom says tim you may be
getting bracketed you may want to set up
security while streaming those who may
want to do harm are watching you right
now give less specifics no i understand
all that um and i i will i will tell you
guys this i i don't mention this very
often but
we're armed of course we are you know
and and so people have mentioned that on
the show like
without getting into too much detail
when we've had other contentious guests
people i've seen comments where they're
like yo tim's strapped like you guys
know this right yeah we're in the middle
of nowhere and i talk about how the fact
like we're we're like crazy 2a people
but we're also very um very safe with
with firearms so it's like not like we
just have guns lying around or anything
crazy like that but we're armed and
we're prepared especially considering
the amount of crazy people who threaten
us and harass us and the death threats
and all that stuff absolutely i mean
that's why i said i was like we were
very lucky nothing happened everything
was calm and the officer was calm and
and no one got hurt because again the
swats are horrible and and they do
injure and kill a lot of people
accidentally we so our front door we've
like
it's it's
it's not like a house door closed and
like bolted locked you can walk up and
there's like a clear glass door like an
office like it's it's it's a screen door
but like when we have uh
i guess what i'm trying to say is when
you have like an office building and
there's you can see through the door and
everything it's very similar you walk up
you can see through the window you can
see there's a desk with the receptionist
and there's a computer so they're
they're not walking into some crazy if
they're not kicking any doors if this
was if we were the only people in here
that would have been a big problem
because just to say i went downstairs i
just run downstairs and grab something
and they come in the house and boom boom
boom and i'm coming down the stairs and
they i don't know they're there they
don't know who i am i'm dressed in all
black
they may they may get spooked and shoot
me that's funny because right before
they came in here i was about to run run
to the bathroom like run fast like
downstairs i could just run inside and
he was counted all over the place and
the crazy thing is often when ian runs
to the bathroom he grabs the master
sword from zelda and swings it wildly
everyone out
and screams
all right let's see dragon lady says man
what could have happened if the cops had
walked in when you were showing your
freaking antique non-working gun to
someone bad ish could go down
yeah
uh
it could i could very well see a cop
just getting spooked man just open the
door and you got a gun and
i can see it happening even if they even
if they know
like you know what the show is
especially if they know that that we
live and work here because then they're
going to be like oh man you know we know
like tim pools obviously guys probably
going to get targeted
there's a good chance as a threat here
you know what i mean we got to foia
everything yeah absolutely yeah easy
that's easy that's easy did you get the
badge numbers from there no no but they
they may have
yeah i'm i'm trying to like run down
they seem like you know it's probably a
very small little agency around this
area yeah
yeah yeah and i've talked to them before
i'll talk to them yeah it'll be fine you
have the right to for you all that stuff
and it would be good to get to get to
meet the
the the person who runs the district
here the sergeant lieutenant yeah just
get in contact with him because you may
need him at some point more so than
calling 9-1-1 you may
contact them directly right and we've
actually
you know we've actually talked with
security companies and stuff like that
so
uh laughing dog says how how how do you
like world government now tim fun stuff
eh
yeah
fun stuff
i mean you've got on the one side
like we've already said now three times
if someone really was hurt here these
guys come running in full speed to make
sure we're okay well you know the worst
factor the one time that you and i want
to share with other people but you would
want to find out is how long did it take
him to get here after the 911 call
happened yeah i got to be honest
i bet it took a long time
who knows you know i mean look i tell i
say it over and over again we're in the
middle of nowhere and we're armed so
i'm willing to bet that
it took him a while
probably not as long as when i was in
miami or anything like that but they're
probably going fast though you know
i don't know i just go fast we're in the
middle of nowhere though i know but they
may be roaming around in the middle of
nowhere i mean this certainly uh uh took
over the show multiple cars obviously
five people wouldn't come in one car so
right yeah they come for a different
direction ponton says you can get uh you
can get a direct line from the cops to a
phone that glows red when it rings and
sits right in front of you during the
show can we make freedom day about
taking back the narrative too procedure
what it is
temporary symptom reducer i'm very into
the public interacting with the police
like private company police it's maybe
not maybe pride but i want to somehow
help the police force with private
enterprise without like creating a
private police force just make the
environment easier and better for them
to to work
somehow i like to do it when i drive i'm
always being as safe as i can as if i'm
a cop like making sure everyone's okay
so that they don't have to so yeah
someone do that with with our
organization that'd be
cool
triumph says
man when i hear and listen to the rock
and a hard place these cops are put in
i'm super happy i'm a garbage man holy
crap
and i can respect that that's why i've
never been like all the all cops are bad
blah blah blah i'm like hey they're
human beings man it's hard man it's hard
dude it's hard to think about okay if i
do this i'm gonna lose my pension some
of these officers i don't know those
guys look kind of young but you got a
guy with 25 years on 28 years on and he
want to be a hero today and lose his
whole pension you know you got to think
man the sacrifice that cops make for 28
years putting your family through all
that they don't know if you're gonna
live or die every day when i was when i
was working i didn't know if i was gonna
die every day every day it's like okay i
made it today made it today made it
today i didn't die today i mean you
don't know any day you could be dead
over anything i mean a traffic violation
or somebody can run a red light and hit
you when you retire did you miss the
exhilaration of that yeah because
adrenaline rush every day is out of
control so
you can't replicate that you know when
you're on duty man your adrenaline is
because you get a call like this two
people shot and murdered or something
one guy is on the phone they can hear
people screaming in the background like
dude that's that yo
you feel something in your in you that
cannot be replicated
we got uh psycho he says leftists on the
serfs on twitch told me you guys are
dangerous personalities
i mean
i don't know who those guys are so if
you mean like stunningly attractively
dangerous yeah
like like dangerous in the sense that if
you're a tyrant or a fascist you better
watch out because we'll expose you these
people are nuts we're just having a
basic conversation well how is this
dangerous won't they have a conversation
walter no no see if you are part of the
cult we are very dangerous we had
marjorie taylor green on the show and
you know what people said we had a ton
of super chats where people were like i
thought she was crazy until i heard her
talk about you know what she thinks and
what she does same thing with steve
bannon yeah that's why they view us as
dangerous because the lies and the
smears that keep people in the cult we
break
you're right they probably think you say
stuff on here and think you're crazy i
mean that's always how it is when people
talk to me or when i see people in
person or i'm in an event live and
people question me that that are
dissenters or whatever they never i mean
we they always leave like i like you man
you're cool yeah i didn't know you
really i watched the surf's before
they're pretty cool so i bet that's kind
of out of context no they rag on us off
but it's like i don't watch the show how
to rag i watch it they seem like there's
like they love bragging all right sure
whatever i don't
when i say i i don't know them i'm not
familiar with what their show format is
or who they are as people or their names
or anything like that i just know that
we get those kind of couple of dudes i
think yeah they just want to sleep with
you that's what it is they're just
trying to date me man
all right you guys the life of dee says
ironically you had marjorie taylor green
on yesterday today you're getting
swatted i'm just pointing out events in
order not drawing conclusions the real
question is what did she tell you about
hillary
gotta watch the amount of not enough
not enough that was a good one
all right let's grab some more super
chats
waffle sensei says brandon you said if a
cop sees someone kill a pedo do they get
to choose whether to arrest that person
yeah written house shot a pedo when he
wasn't arrested the cops have the
discretion no it's not that's the
exact that's not true you gotta develop
probable cause so if you because kyle
reading house they didn't really have
all the the context of what actually
happened they know people were shot
he came over to the police i don't think
they knew who was the wrong wrong or not
i don't think they even knew someone got
shot at that point and they don't know
the guy's appeal anyway they just they
hear shots people are down they don't
know who shot who they don't know if
it's a self-defense or not and so it
wasn't a discretionary decision they
didn't have probable cause to arrest him
which you can't arrest anybody unless
you have probable cause and if you
arrest him without probable cause all of
that evidence goes away and you are
probably going to get fired and there'll
be a cop again deservingly so
just jimmy says foia requests info about
officers that came and any info you can
get about call absolutely and then we'll
publish it
yeah we will especially the phone call i
want to listen to that voice because who
knows maybe we know who it is like i had
crazy things throughout my career where
people called me like one o'clock in the
morning and i remember recording them
and then i remember that person who was
harassing me over the years calling my
family getting these numbers was
actually a part of my organization in
new york city and i had the recording
and i played it back right in front of
this person who was infiltrating my
organization and just harassing me and
that was a huge wake-up call so there's
a lot of weird people out there
there's a lot of crazy people out there
so just having this information is key
and make sure if you go to four-year
requests and they say it's under
investigation they can't release it
maybe you can go down and view it
they'll they they may let you actually
view or listen to the phone call without
taking possession of it you know
i should do
you know what i'm not going to say it
don't say security secret secrets yeah
perfect
we'll uh we'll keep that our security
plans a secret so what i was going to
say is um my cauliculture style booby
traps yes
hang some paint cans from the top of the
stairs yes no but you're not it's
actually illegal yeah i found
yeah he gets it to booby trap stuff but
like you know then cause then the cops
come in
bernard you remember i just never that
scene i think that flamethrower or
something blew his and he had a beating
like this
it was a part two i freaking loved that
movie it was so funny when i was a kid i
should just watch it yeah we watched
part two over christmas you have to have
to man
all right jjg says tim why go to new
jersey you can't bear arms
uh why go to new jersey you can't bear
arms in maryland md police will arrest
you for having a firearm on you which is
why i'm for dems wanting to disarm
police if i can't they can't same with
self-defense
well we're we're we're actually setting
up the new freedom stand in west
virginia the contracts are in the
deposits are in construction is
beginning soon and i think maybe in six
months we will have the fully
operational new facility
but that will just be the studio and
then we have to actually build out the
rest of the open space it's going to be
it's going to be amazing i can't believe
that we're getting this done it's going
to be absolutely incredible
i'm not for disarming police by the way
i'm for disarming some police i i don't
think never wow
uh i think we'd be we if we had some
cops who weren't armed for certain jobs
we'd be we'd have more versatility but
like what job would you not need to be
armed as a police officer well so like
uh
it depends on the call i suppose if
there's like uh
what's a good example
uh a working dog
well i don't know about a dog because
dogs can be dangerous no just a barking
dog you don't have to deal with it it's
just a it's a it's a civil complaint
right right a person saying the dogs are
too loud i'm thinking
businesses you know someone's
complaining noise complaints you know
but see but let me just give you an
example barking dog call that's why i
was going to set you up a little bit so
but the barking dog caught it just
happened not too long ago um they went
to an apartment complex and the police
officers got ambushed and one got
murdered while she was begging for her
life with our own guns that and it was a
barking dog call so it's like you never
know like what's what that's why i'm
like you know i i
i think there are circumstances in which
we can have officers who don't need to
be armed that way i think they should be
armed they just need proficient i was
armed and i never shot anybody i was on
a swat team never shot anybody you don't
you don't have to shoot people but
actually i'll take it i'll take this
back i think everybody should be armed
well here's here's a perfect here's a
perfect segue into and i know you got
the super chats but you know uh
one of the things that i'm into now is
that i'm an advisor with a company
called quest microsystems and we've
developed a non-lethal weapon that you
can use in law enforcement and personal
defense but this is a this is a thing
that's important for our society because
i would love for a police officer to
have a gun and have another
qualified weapon that they can use when
they get to a call and it's like a man
who's loony but he didn't have a weapon
non-lethal or less lethal and can we
test it out
yes shot show shot show you're gonna
shot a show in vegas we'll have them
available we'll just test them out
they're non-lethal we'll do a couple
more and then we're gonna head over to
that member segment we've got a couple
uh different super chats that said that
we got insurrected by the cops on
january 6 and that january 6 will
forever be the day that tim cast ireland
was was uh was swatted and that's what
we're gonna remember is that why
somebody did that i don't know no so
they could be the anniversary rush i
gotta be honest the podcast i think it
might be marjorie taylor green
oh because she was on here yeah yeah
maybe they hate me because i'm a
foreigner i don't think i don't think
it's you
and um
i think maybe they wanted just to see it
happen you know that's one of the
reasons the live show well with the
possibility of someone getting seriously
hurt here i don't think it was anything
but to try to cause malicious harm
that's my perspective so um you know
when you have someone like mtg on you
you generate a lot of attention
obviously the establishment really
despised sorry the activists really hate
her i don't think she had anything to do
with in that regard right i think it
just get put us on the on the radar for
a lot of a lot of that's what i agree
with because i'll say they would have
done it on the day she was here
that would have made more sense but also
the some wacko
saw her on here and now is aware of it
exactly i was aware of the show
i think some people i think some people
don't they're not they don't understand
the seriousness of the severity of
swatting i think some people think uh
this would be funny to interrupt the
show they don't think about that it's a
felony
and some kid got like 20 years in prison
for swatting yeah
full speed past cops and not knowing why
they're there and yelling at me to the
bathroom i couldn't that could have
happened
let's let's we have a lot to talk about
in regards to uh especially that other
swatting too so let's do that over on
the members segment we'll get in depth
on policing debate the morality
authoritarianism libertarians etc so
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
what what time did it happen it was like
51 851-ish yeah so it's possible it's
possible that uh it took them like an
hour to get here and maybe they called
it at night when the show oh no way it's
again
yeah but i was like that's a weird time
unless they're getting all the five
officers together in the difference
when i was saying a long time i was
thinking like
eight ten minutes yeah but then i was
looking at the time i was like i wonder
when this was called because i know
where they are oh they're nearby and i
know how fast they can go but because
we're in a rural area if they if they
have the lights on and we're speeding
i'm thinking like eight times response
time is about 15 minutes
in some in rural areas now i don't know
how rural this is compared to places in
texas that i you know places that when i
work in texas average response time is
10 minutes according to a u.s study
released in 2017 right in here in this
area well let's let's let's all right
all right we'll do the member assignment
we'll get into the cop stuff for sure so
smash that like button subscribe to the
show uh share the show with your friends
you can follow the show timcast ira
basically everywhere follow us on
instagram you can follow me at timcast
on instagram where i post uh i don't
know i don't know whatever i post a
weird garbage so follow it if you like
it uh you want to shout anything out
brandon no no just book being black and
blue
uh being a black cop in america on the c
is very proud of the book doing very
well i may give you insight into law
enforcement and also the quest micro
systems that i'm a part of investor
i'm an advisor with them it's a publicly
traded company and it's going to take
over the landscape of
non-lethal weapons in law enforcement
and personal defense where can people
find you if they want to contact you
they can find me at the office of
tatum.com the officertating.com so i
have my own media organization and
youtube channel on we are change i did a
full video on exactly what i was talking
about when the police officers came in
the history of pandemics and civil
unrest check out that video if you
haven't yet i also released another
video on lukeoncensort.com about the
great reset hope to see some of you guys
there i'm working my butt off and uh you
know this is
we're really in a key crucial critical
time where we got to do as much work as
we can before it's too late so i want to
thank everyone a part of this mission
and getting the message out there our
work i think is more important than ever
thank you so much for being here thank
you luke hey you guys check me out ian
crossland.net thanks for coming i love
you and uh be good to yourself and your
friends
thank you guys all very much for tuning
in for this extra exciting episode of
tim cast irl this is the kind of high
quality content you can expect from this
podcast i'm just kidding you don't get
this kind of stuff on rogan though i'm
just saying anyway you guys can follow
me on twitter at sourpatchlets thanks
for hanging out everybody we will see
you all over at timcast.com and our
member segments where we uh we're gonna
talk about cops and stuff we'll see you
there
you